Hello, everybody!
Okay, look.
It was not my fault.
I was late this time.
Okay, I was ready.
I was so ready.
But the reason why I was a little bit late today is because
their game wasn't downloadable until launch day.
And then, even then, even then, they didn't put it up.
They didn't put up the download button until five to six
minutes later.
So it is not my fault.
This time, this time I take zero responsibility, okay guys,
I might have taken responsibility like in the past, but I
know for this one time, I do not take responsibility for
being late.
It was, it was not my fault.
Okay, at one point, I almost let the intrusive thoughts win
and like, because I was like, We're download button.
We're download button.
And I was like on Twitch.
I was like, did anyone else got the download button on
Twitch?
Because I was like seeing like, oh, maybe some Twitch
Weemer.
So I got the download button.
And then I saw like Bandai was doing an official launch
stream of Sandland where they were like, you know, hyping up
Sandland.
And I almost typed in chat.
We're done.
I was gonna be one of those people Because they were like Oh
the gods are happy Because I was watching it Because I was
like Watching I was like Oh maybe don't know Don't tell us
if there's a delay And then And then they were like We hope
you enjoyed Sandland Get Oh it's up We hope you enjoy it
It's up now guys Go and download Sandland For the official
launch Like on that official stream And I was gonna I was
like I was typing us ready I was like we're down so ready I
almost was like we're down though I almost I almost did it
but I didn't let the intrusive thoughts win this time I
didn't become a Karen I was like okay I'll wait
I'll wait a little bit but also because the moment I was
about to type it button showed up so i was saved by the
download button i was saved by the download button actually
showing up so so i didn't i didn't embarrass myself today in
front of i didn't embarrass myself in front of the poor pr
people at bandai because i think they were like they were
also like oh no where is the download button uh use it thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you dude thank you
super chat thank you thank you all right for those who don't
know this game um this is sandland uh it is a game that's
based off the manga manga slash anime uh from akira toriama
and obviously this is like one of the first games that are
released you know post what's the word post hum hum i can't
pronounce it but you know um uh salute to akira toriama But
this was the first game to be released afterwards.
And, you know, I've been super hyped to check it out.
And I'm looking forward to it.
Apparently, I was like, I was like sort of like hesitant on
trying this out.
Because I saw it was like RPG.
But then I read that it was like action RPG.
So I was like, I like action.
Maybe the action will balance out the RPG.
maybe i was like maybe the action part will balance that out
and because like i'm not like a super because i don't really
have that much of an attention span for like rpgs and stuff
um rpgs are good don't get look it is called preferences and
and and and like i do not have the attention span for RPGs
especially like JRPGs because like I have such a low
attention span when it comes to like reading that that lore
goes from one ear to the other and then it disappears and I
would be playing the RPG part and I'd be like what the fuck
is going on I'd be like who's this guy again wait what's the
character who am I playing as what is her story I don't know
And then what I use Okay Here's a little tidbit about me
That will make you understand it more So in Pokemon games
When you select moves I make sure all my Pokemon moves Are
just straight on full attack I don't care about stats or
anything Like things that would get rid of stats Or and all
that stuff I just what I see the PP move And I was like does
more damage okay all four of my moves are ultimate damage
and so like you see that for pokemon that's four moves now
imagine like i play a jrpg slash rpg and it's all my moves
i'd be like okay all my moves just do damage in all my 20
moves that i have RPG that's all I know
and then if I if I am low okay do I have any heals oh I
don't because I put all my I put all my skills in just
damage oh okay so that is why that is why like for me I know
that I know that like the and jrpg stuff like i know for me
is definitely not my strongest suit so i was like okay maybe
the i saw i was watching the gameplay of it and i was like
oh okay i see a lot of open world action in there i was like
oh all right i can work with that i can work with the open
world part and i was like oh tanks i can work with that i
can work with the tanks too And I was like, all right, this
is good.
This is good.
This is it.
I'm going to I'm going to try this out And then if you never
see a part two of this game, then you know why Dark Blade,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Every time you talk about reading You further prove this
hair that it's by both dragoons and you can't read.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Here you go.
Oh, I mean, it seems all right.
I think
Press any key.
Is my sound guy here today?
Is my sound guy here?
Ooh.
Oh my god.
By the way, I pre-ordered the deluxe version.
Because I was like, I want to be special.
I want to pay to win.
A game that I don't know if we're going to get a part two
on.
I was like, I don't know if I'm going to get a part two.
But ooh, more items.
that means I have more items that can affect my gameplay
let's fucking go all right 120 FPS limit and then I think
that's good you don't come yes save these settings okay all
right obviously voice has to always be up I feel like just
up the voice guys I don't guys I don't know if sound guys
here so today in one of those rare moments we're gonna let
the chat figure Are any of my mods here?
Oh, no.
This might be...
This might get a little rowdy.
I'll increase it a bit louder.
Oh, no.
What's that word call when we have actual...
When we have no leaders in place?
Oh, no.
No, not the chaos
Anarchy, oh no, it's going to be an anarchy now There's no,
none of the mods are here Um Casually enjoy Okay, I'm not
going to do hard I don't know what this game is going to be
like Guys, I'm going to do normal I don't have any If it was
an FPS game With like zero Resource were like zero like like
it was a scarce resource shit then it would be fine Who
needs mod when there is oh Oh Miracle, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
You think that but then when you become a real when you
become an an actual streamer Then then you realize Having
mods might might not be a bit may not be a bad idea Because
giving chat too much power It's a little stupid
If chat has too much power It'll just be Twitch It'll just
be a YouTube play Sandland Oh my god Oh my god Monty here
Guys guys our Monty Okay Alright Other silent You're gonna
be my designated sound guy I know you have zero like
Experience But I trust you Today you're gonna learn You're
gonna learn to be the new sound guide My substitute sound
guide Scattery Alright I'm a little worried that this is
taking a long time to save Oh wait Oh wait Oh it's telling
me I thought I thought it was saving my game i was like i
was like why is this taking so long to say
i was like damn oh
look it's a little ghost i love his style it's so
recognizable i love that he just really loves to draw
vehicles too i feel like he became a manga artist just to
draw sick-ass vehicles.
Oh
my god, sound guys here!
JK, JK, other mod.
You're fired and rehired to be, like, regular mod now.
The actual, no benefits, by the way.
No overtime.
No, uh...
No, no firing package, by the way.
What the fuck?
I never read or watched the anime of Sandland so this is
zero context for me I
think that's called a deep
motion what happens if I lose him bro there's no way I can
lose him there's no way I could go if I can't even run off
into the distance I can't even run off into the distance bro
I can't
Yeah, no severance pay, by the way.
Who are those guys?
Demons!
Step!
I've been spotted.
Okay, that guy's just a centaur.
I can't believe he grouped up the centaur with an actual...
Oh, shit!
I'm sorry.
I was trying to be a streamer.
All right, here we go.
Yay!
Don't lose him.
Okay, not gonna lie.
All right.
This is a little bit of a nitpicky, but like, I hate the
subtitle font.
the subtitle font is pretty pretty bad oh my god they're in
the middle of nowhere thanks for the water you're just gonna
leave them to die you're a demons demons don't need water i
mean he's a fucking demon how are they gonna drive back this
is why i mean desert or jungle this is exactly why i'm like
being stuck in the middle of the desert is there's no water
what the fuck are you gonna do got to wait for their moves
oh i was gonna say powerful oh wait work on me anyway,
right?
Shoot me.
Come on.
Yeah, it does nothing.
There's no sense of... There's no sense of, like, actual
urgency.
That's my chance?
What?
Oh, epic attack.
There you go.
Get over here.
I'm gonna beat you up, too.
over here that's lucky right get over here get over here
come on get over here stop running away get over here get
over right get over here you can't run away from me come on
get over here well you're full HP already but beat the shit
out of you get over here come on come on stop running away
all right nice and they
back into the sand you go the nature nature absorbed them
okay who the fuck his name is remnant oh my god there's a
little ferret kid too all right let's rumble all right let's
boost up the volume a little bit oh wait i can actually
boost up the volume within the in-game settings what am i
doing all right which i like how if i don't press anything
is just be like oh my god i have a couple of seconds of
silence we're only taking a bit pleasure doing business
all right we leave them to a little bit i just took
everything they're not just took all his fucking water don't
see much point in stealing a few sips of water at a goal
like this i say it's high time we hijacked the king's entire
water source for ourselves oh it's like mad max It's like
Japan Mad Max Because like He has all the water
Alright let me Guys apparently you can't go to the menu You
can't go to the menu While you're talking
It's Anime Australia Exactly What is is it prince what are
you doing make that kid pay hey you it's water take it water
thank you yeah but what if she drinks all the water after
that he's still gonna die you didn't solve you didn't solve
anything i couldn't believe my eyes if we're gonna start
doing good deeds we might as well turn in our pitchforks
torment the kid plenty once he grows up if he's gonna grow
up you're just delaying it he'll die regardless he still has
no source of water
joshua thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank
you why is young maging boo cruising around with a trolley
dokey i don't think mad max had so on center that's right
it's a better version of mad max
Who the fuck is this guy?
Can't remember the last time I had water.
Thanks a bunch.
Oh, oh, this is a different centaur.
Who's he?
By the way, Prince.
It sounds like slimes at death's door.
Wait, who's dying?
Huh?
Who the fuck is slime?
I think he accidentally fell asleep in the...
the sun again it might not be too late yet would you please
go bring him some water prince many thank you the super chat
thank you thank you madden max if it was good
just because it's anime it doesn't mean it's better than the
original guys
it's like okay To be fair, the anime Bible is sort of better
than the regular Okay,
this is my opinion Okay, guys, so in case I get canceled or
anything Just remember, this was my opinion But I think
anime Jesus is a bit better than the regular Jesus
Hey, aren't you just pushing your chores on me?
it i am tied up with other tasks though huh fine you know no
anime jesus the bible actually has a manga slash anime based
off of it all right after accepting a new quest a quest icon
will appear on the map to show where you should go to
progress the quest oh yeah sound guy should i increase the
overall volume including voice or is it just like some parts
of the game because there's like uh Oh, I can dash.
Oh, thank God.
I can run faster because we have, we have multiple.
Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay.
Oh, yeah, this is like first day launch stuff.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
We realize, guys, we realize what launch day is going to be
like.
Oh, oh, oh.
Maybe it's just this place You know, maybe Oh, okay, we have
to read this Those soldiers in the water transport Why does
he have a voice They hiding something From the army, you
think Huh?
How should I know?
Okay, okay, he has a voice Everybody else, fuck the other
guys, I guess Fuck that one centaur in general Ha ha ha
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
I have to go this way.
I wonder how many of these NPCs are just one guy doing like
10 voices.
Oh, Prince.
Could you do something for me?
Next time you go out of town, get me Raptor Scales.
Could he please?
Raptor Scales.
Oh, it's not even a regular side quest.
Hey.
Here, have some water.
We're free?
What kind of fucking demon are you?
Water toadout.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Using that logic, does that mean non-animated dokey bird is
better than animated dokey bird?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're a demon.
You can't die from dehydration.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, I've learned my lesson.
Here, take this as thanks.
Oh, I get stuff.
Oh, my God.
I got something in return.
I got B-grade steel.
Nice.
All right, at least, I guess helping people is good
sometimes.
I guess sometime it's good.
Oh, I just, like, walked away from him.
Was I supposed to help him?
I liked how I was supposed to talk to him I was like alright
anyway and the game was like wait come back wait did you
forgot this one kid whoa are you alright got some water for
you and I'm gonna die here you go here's some water I guess
I'm running out
It's just a side character.
Leave him.
By the way, raise up the volume.
Let me know if it's better.
Sound guy.
Yeah, you know what?
Fuck the humans.
If we let more humans die, there's more chances for them to
become demons.
So smart.
Alright, we go.
Oh yeah, go talk to us.
slime.
Because apparently he's also dying.
Oh, I can double jump now.
Oh.
Hello.
Is that him?
Oh, I thought I could step on him.
Hello.
I don't think he looks okay.
No.
There's still time.
Throw it on him now.
No.
No need to yell.
But if he's the slime king and I'm the prince demon, it
would be a shame.
Okay, it would be a shame if I don't do it in time.
Wait, actually.
It would be such a shame if I...
If we ran out of time.
Oh, no.
Long live the king.
think you can save him god what a waste of water also how
much water is in this bottom well probably yeah thomas thank
you for your favorite super chat thank you thank you and my
donkey bird jojo stands tomato
no oh my water this is the king
Thought you were a gunner Uh-huh, great why is your voice so
dang loud?
Yeah, quest complete
Stop falling asleep in the Sun would you just a regular guy?
I thought they said slime king He's just a regular slime.
I wasted all my water on this one slime I
should have been survival of the fittest if he was dumb
enough to get like melted by the sun he did not deserve to
live why the world have to end up like this we need to we
need to have powerful slimes around 50 years now ever since
man's foolishness and a succession of natural disasters be a
kind ruler what's that What does that mean?
I said bring up the volume a little bit more already.
I just brought up the volume.
Well, they just kept on waiting their pointless wars.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh, no, I didn't realize the ammo was limited.
Nice.
Boom.
No, I missed!
No!
Okay, got it.
World of tanks time.
Anime World of tanks.
Just like anime Mad Max.
How do I do my Nitro?
Like this?
What am I supposed to do?
Boom.
Oh, that's it?
Just one shot?
Yeah, Tori, I'm a loved vehicles.
Is that a woman?
Oh no, that's a helmet.
I thought that was hair.
planet
just because of one stupid mistake man i wish somebody would
have make a compilation of like all his like vehicle art or
vehicle designs they're all so creative too so what are we
doing out here under the blazing sun
in some alternate universe instead of teslas we would have
toriyama vehicles this scorching desolate desert sand land
why man I wonder why
but a chance encounter is about to change this dying
wasteland forever oh my god is the iconic is the iconic toy
on my car or bike
girl Sandlot Boma!
Mr.
Hercules!
That's right.
I'm a human.
I come from a neighboring town.
But like, what if he just has no muscles?
I want to ask for you demons' help.
Now, is one of your leaders willing to listen to what i have
to say
oh my god mr satan i don't know why i said mr hercules he
even has an s for a badge
you've got guts showing your face around here i see him as
hercules instead of satan so are you the demon's leader
that's me the great king lucifer is our Oh, that's my dad.
Hercules was his Christian name.
I'm the fiend prince Beals above.
Oh, his English name is Hercules.
I knew it.
I was like, oh my God, did I actually fucked up?
I watched Dragon Ball Z so much.
How did I confuse Hercules and Satan?
State your business.
I was like, okay, I might not have recently watched Dragon
Ball.
Bob, but I grew up with that.
How the fuck did I mess that up?
I like your assistance with my mission.
Searching for the legendary spring.
The legendary spring?
Explain.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Love the content.
It's not a problem.
Will you mind wishing my friend Giggles a happy birthday?
It'll mean a lot to her.
Of course.
Happy birthday to you.
you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear giggles happy
birthday to you yeah you must have sunstroke or something
what oh sorry do you know a bird called the waterfinch a
waterfinch this bird feeds on small freshwater fish and
during its mating season flies north to lay eggs among the
rocky cliffs there it's still alive that's so beef it still
exists hmm it does sound familiar but how exactly is this
relevant because I saw a waterfinch flying north yesterday
oh my god that means there's water this means there must be
a spring with small fish to sustain these birds somewhere in
this There must not be a lot, though, because it's just one
pool of water.
But the desert to the south of here is dangerous and wild.
I doubt a lone human could make it even so far as halfway
across.
That's why I'm here.
I would like for a powerful demon to accompany me on my
journey.
Let's say we somehow managed to find this string.
Yeah, but what if we end up, like, eating all the food?
fish in the spring because like humans or demons are greedy
motherfuckers and because of that and then the fit and then
the birds will die and then we're gonna ruin the ecosystem
and then we're gonna have another global warming of course
if you like you're even free to live there yourself yeah two
by two water pod bro like it's a fucking spring not a lake
all we ask is to be allowed to take water we need to get by
so tell me is all this your idea or are you here on behalf
of the king there's a king too it's my plan alone is your
you guys have a king as well as if that greedy tyrant cares
for anyone other than himself i don't think the world can
get any warmer dokey must find this spring by ourselves for
the people
doesn't sound like a bad deal but we've been doing fine
stealing water for ourselves how about it working with a
human yeah why don't we trick him to tell us where the
spring is and then kill him please accept this as a token of
goodwill what the fuck is that like a playstation
Electricity which needs water The two game consoles to have
survived these chaotic times.
Oh my god, bro.
He gave me a playstation Pills, thank you for the tent get
this just thank you.
Thank you Don't I need water for to run electricity?
Is that that's a sad thing?
It looks like a PlayStation 1 to me.
I never had a Sega Saturn.
I thought it was a PlayStation 1 But like what if it's
black?
But it was like copyright free PlayStation 1
How are we guys how are we gonna play this game?
How are we gonna plug in the Sega Saturn?
There's still wind power does this look like we have?
have wind solar powered dude does this look like we live in
a place that has electricity guys
join what like how's so that got any good dirt I like how
this guy has has voice acting oh heard about the peachy
prince uh yeah peachy that rings a bell what's that Their
aliens supposedly came to earth about 70 years ago And
shared their super advanced tech with humans I hear they've
all been wiped out by this point though Guys, if we had
electricity we would not be using fire as our light source
If we have solar powered because god damn we have so much
solar Okay, it's...
Where is it?
Is it near?
I assume it's here because there's guards.
I hear you.
Magic, maybe.
I've yet to see anything that's powered by energy, guys.
Maybe it's the aesthetic.
Fire saves electricity.
Doki, you don't understand.
but we got tanks and cars we don't know if the demons have
tanks and cars we just saw the humans
hey dad oh what that's that guy in drag i think i was like
everything from dragon ball z i heard aid him let humans
plan will benefit us as well the buddha and he seems
trustworthy enough and it gives you a chance to sharpen your
skills yes sir that said once you return you're only allowed
to use that console for one hour one hour I'm already only
20 minutes away from one hour be sure to only play in
tutorial in kingdom hearts not even half that's like
one-fourth of a tutorial that's like 20 of the tutorial in
kingdom hearts
we're going in this how many passengers can fit Olivia, can
we fit our centaur?
Two.
Centaur.
He's, look at him.
He has abs.
Thief, I guess.
What?
He's old.
Centaur has abs.
Look at him.
You're good at stealing.
Bro, he doesn't even get the car.
Just run behind us.
Grinch, I just thought of something.
Wouldn't it be easier to have someone who can fly, carry you
there?
Quit complaining and get your butt in here right now.
No, it's because he's strong.
Like, we...
Bro, he can just run after us with his horse legs.
Head to the legendary spring.
Believe in the old guy Two old men instead one why in
balance too many old men, please pick support
Call me Ralph, well, and well probably quite some time Hey,
let me take the wheel for a bit leave the human machines to
their makeup Sure, take it for a spin.
For real?
Oh my god, I'm gonna learn how to drive!
I'm gonna get my first driving lesson!
Can he, like, touch the pedals?
Like, he's so short!
Alright.
Autopilot.
Oh my god, thank god.
Alright, boost, break.
I'm gonna fast travel to towns or camps where I've been in
the map menu.
Will the cursor or desire to hold X and X to travel there?
Fast travel might be disabled.
Let's see.
Why to leave vehicle?
Autopilot.
Break.
Okay.
That's the autopilot.
Can you guys tell?
JK, that was actually me.
That was actually me.
I tricked you guys.
JK, that was actually autopilot.
Oh, I can boost an autopilot.
Can I like...
Oh.
Get rid of...
Okay.
I can get rid of autopilot if I Wait, what happens if I go
like Wee Oh, okay, so I don't Oh, guys!
Did you see that?
I drove off the cliff And it took me closer to the
destination It's the secret It's the secret, guys!
Okay, no, JK I'm not excited JK, it was, I was just next to
it You have HP?
Where?
There's no HP.
Oh my god, I can drift.
Look at that.
I'm drifting.
Am I drifting?
I can't tell.
I still can't come to terms with just how fast the outside
world is.
There you go.
We're doing it.
We're speeder on strap.
It used to be even bigger.
And there were no vehicles.
Civilization truly made the world smaller.
Wait, what's that over there?
There's something over here.
Wait.
I gotta take a break here.
There's stuff there.
You guys see that?
Look.
What's over here?
There has to be stuff in this cave, right?
Oh my god, look at all this loot!
Oh, I can't punch a scorpion.
Nine out of ten.
Can't punch scorpions.
Oh my god, I already got loot.
Guys.
Look at all this loot that I got.
Nice.
Alright.
We gotta go back vegetable oil.
Oh my god.
I can cook now too.
I got vegetable oil All right.
Whoa, what's that?
Get out Wait, did you see that?
Oh my god.
What is that?
Oh, I'm gonna run it.
Oh Okay, now it's a 10 out of 10 game again
Now now it's a 10 out of 10.
I'm gonna run over the babies first
Don't get no, that's right Oh my god, it's switching Don't
worry, I need a double tap It's not the baby's Don't get
there we go Alright, let's leave I get one experience for
that That's so fucked up up all right there you go let's
leave now no i overheated oh is that more babies oh no she
doesn't she's not adopted look see i i introduced a mom to
new babies that she can adopt i realized there were guys no
you don't understand you don't understand guys i saw the
baby is up there with no mom so the obviously i had to make
sure they get adopted so i made i found a mom that had
babies and then I killed those babies so then the mom can
adopt the new babies and then we solved the all orphan
problem.
I'm a hero.
I gave those babies a mom.
Whoa, what the fuck?
I gave you dragon and it's hungry.
I literally ran over some babies what do you mean Okay the
Genji dragon will chase after your car It like burials deep
under the earth Oh we're dune now At anime dune time Clear
it to you then used to dodge left and right Okay I just need
to dodge The scent Ooh know where I'm going if I just go
left and right there's no way he wouldn't know where I'm
going if I just if I'm just left and right all the time oh
shit did I miss how oh god oh god okay maybe I'm going as
fast what how am I supposed to
I don't know how he knows every time every time maybe stop
zigzagging no I don't know man I don't guys I don't know
guys I should stop zigzagging I just figured it out I'm
trying it won't let me boost oh my god it does He doesn't
let me boost!
I can just drive!
I'm trying.
I'm driving as fast as I can, bro.
Grandpa, I'm literally driving the fastest I can.
No!
Our materia is!
Turn around!
He's already dead!
Turn around and get our shit back!
not our supply that was our like that was our one month
supplies that we just lost
we're barely outside the village and we've lost all our food
and water we lost all our food water we all
right well i guess we lost all of it
so what should we do without provisions surely our only
choice is to turn back yeah how the fuck are you survive
with no food or water i knew i should have looted those
babies you know there should be a town called talbo not too
far from here not that i have any money but we'll figure
something out we don't have money you're a sheriff he's
broke what do you mean we don't have money i'm a child
Oh, what's this?
There's a duck here.
What is that?
Shucks, it's just a toy duck.
It's got bite marks, too.
They must have been so hungry.
They'd even eat a toy.
Oh, no.
That's no laughing matter.
Those poor children.
There's no military food relief here.
And bandits are rampant.
It's no wonder the people would starve.
My God.
Rumor hasn't that starving.
drove them horrible cannibals horrible like what like their
own fucking kind prince some things are better left unsaid
why because we're talking about humans doing something
something that is taboo even to us cannibalism is
cannibalism are lied oh not murder
It's not murder, but cannibalism is our line here.
And yet, they must have been in dire straits to come so
close to breaking that taboo.
So you're saying this toy like symbolizes a taboo.
That's kind of cool.
I'll keep it.
Cannibalism, bad.
Murder, okay.
Nice, I got a toy.
Wait, there's people here.
Where are all the people?
Oh, there's no people there.
Wait, is he bad?
Are you bad?
Oh, oh.
There's people here.
There's Riku.
Okay, you don't have to yell.
And you what?
See, I was headed for Talbo, but I couldn't find the arch
landmark and got hopelessly lost.
I thought I was a goner until I came across a traveling
merchant in this ghost town.
But now I know I'm a goner.
Why'd I have to run into demons of all things?
It must be my destiny to die here.
But such a fraidy cat, he sure can talk.
Cool it, we're not gonna kill you.
Just go.
Really?
Thanks!
Not until you give me shit.
I'm just gonna let him go?
I'm just gonna let this man go?
That's it?
That's his entire plot?
Oh hey, there's a...
There's a traveler.
Can I beat up this dinosaur?
Oh, I can't.
Who is he?
Is he a merchant in this world?
Please!
I'm begging you, just don't steal my soul!
Anything but that!
I can't steal souls.
And even if I could, why would I want to?
What is my purpose?
As a demon.
What can I do?
How am I different from a regular person then?
Sure changed his tune quickly.
Louder voices?
Okay, I'll...
Up the voices, guys.
Now lower the sound.
I have a tail.
So you don't live here?
All right.
Of course not.
This village was abandoned ages ago.
Why is that?
Well, this and that happened and the residents went away.
How about being less vague?
This whole village was built from the ground up during the
Old War to create a safe place to send civilian evacuees.
The Old War?
Oh, the one with the tanks?
so did the royal army supply shipments that cut down the
population lickety split and as if that was oh it's like
survival to finish started raiding the place once the army
pulled out of the area what you see before you is the result
you'd better watch out for bandits yourselves like petty
thieves are gonna see can i run over the bandits well you
never can't be too careful you know what they say an ounce
of prevention's worth a pound of cure on that note check out
my wares they're sure to come in handy on your travels what
do you have for sale okay before that and you're like oh oh
oh guys we're never gonna look at the menu okay okay guys
okay we're gonna
guys give me a sec i'm gonna Guys, this is just launched,
guys.
Okay, this game...
Guys, let me...
Guys, okay.
This game...
This game just launched, okay?
Please, please be kind.
Okay, I'm gonna lower the BGM and...
And the effect so we can up the...
So we can up the overall sound with the game volume.
Okay, let's see.
I up the voice volume.
to 100 and then i'm gonna up the i'm gonna up the sound a
little bit too all right here you go all right there we go
all right we're just never gonna look at the menu
what can i buy strength serum and i can sell stuff too oh i
can sell the raptor skill oh enhance the strength of metals
okay sending your hospital bills send your hospital bills
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe humans actually managed to live here until
recently.
How's the volume now, guys?
There's no place like home.
Which means they must have had an even more powerful reason
to leave.
You know what that guy sounds like?
The sheriff?
He sounds like the new mayor from Family Guy.
The one that replaced Adam West.
Can I beat up a bird?
Here we go.
Alright, there you go.
Let's see.
We gotta go this way.
Wait, why can't I drive over here?
Make sure to check your gear every now and then.
Bookier.
You never know when something you've picked up might come in
handy.
I'm gonna put on autopilot.
Got it.
Guys, this is autopilot.
Guys, that was autopilot, guys.
Okay, autopilot just makes you drive straight.
I've learned what autopilot is.
Let's head for that stone arch Talbot's just beyond it Yeah,
it's about time All right, oh my god autopilot is literally
just drive straight We're right, wait, I can't run over a
dog not dog I'm a a dinosaur, but I can run over.
Oh, I can never mind.
I just need more I just need more speed Yeah, something
would break one XP Was it really better in the old days
Wait, Luke but humans had plenty of problems back then to
look perhaps so but we were never half as cruel as you
demons What the fuck did we demons do tricks on people, but
we don't kill we don't kill Oh, I killed, oh, um, yeah,
guys, I did not kill, guys.
Humanity has always loved to play us for anything and
everything under the sun.
When the river dried up, I bet you all said it must be the
demon's fault, didn't you?
Guys, look at what they said.
They said I don't care, guys.
They said I don't care.
This might turn out to be useful later.
better now or is overall sound better chat just want to be
sure guys i didn't kill guys those bugs are just in the
hospital with like broke a broken leg guys oh my god there's
green dinosaurs oh my god they have babies too oh my god
it's a mom dad oh don't worry i'm only here for the babies
other orphan dynos.
I need to create.
I need to create families that need babies to adopt all the
other orphans.
I am doing.
Oh, she does mom has triplets.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
No, I killed the mom.
No.
Okay.
Now I have to find.
Now I have to find a single, single mom to adopt these
babies.
I created orphans.
I can't believe I've done the one.
Okay.
We're going to leave one No, we can't have any survivor or
they're gonna do a revenge plot on me It's time to end the
bloodline now.
So there's no revenge plots.
There you They're orphans now.
There's there were no orphans.
What do you mean?
No witnesses guys no witnesses
Now hold on don't get the wrong idea We totally are Where is
that him?
Oh shit!
And went to bed without brushing my teeth.
Guys, oh my god, it's the king of all...
It's the king of all dragons.
How about you old man?
That you've committed a minor sin or two.
Come on, let's get it out.
Am I doing any damage to the Alpha Raptor?
Many men.
I don't know, I can't tell.
What?
It was in war, yes.
All right, we're gonna kill the alpha Did I just chop off
this tail?
Oh my god, he's okay.
He's okay.
He's still moving.
Where's the alpha?
Where is he?
I'm gonna punch the alpha, Dano.
Be careful, Prince What's he gonna do?
Punch me?
Oh, shit.
I don't, I can't.
Are you?
There's the alpha scorpion, too?
What?
What an alpha?
alpha scorpion and an alpha dino love each other very much
oh my god imagine the babies they would make it's level one
how is that alpha do you think the thief will be okay okay
oh i don't have like bro you can't oh you can't okay i'm
gonna say where the fuck is the hp okay i'm gonna fight him
Watch this.
Oh!
Okay, wait.
Don't watch it.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, guys, guys.
Guys, I realize, guys, not every...
Guys, I realize not every dino I can fight, guys.
I just figured it out that I should not take every fight,
chat.
I...
There are some points in time when it's okay to run away.
Alright, we have to go this way.
This is where we have to go.
But anyway, I didn't get to...
Oh, on OBS Remastering Game, just bring it up a little small
bit to round it out.
Okay, guys, close your eyes.
Close your eyes, guys.
Close your eyes real quick, guys.
Okay.
Speed run.
That's a bandit symbol.
They use them to mark off their territory.
Where?
There's a baby all by himself.
I like the sound of that.
How about a little preemptive bandit butt kicking?
No.
Do not approach them under any circumstances.
Understood.
Fine.
Hey, see.
Did the demon village always used to be where it is now?
Where's the bandit symbol?
want to go there there is no record of us moving where's the
bandit symbol i want to go to the band oh shit there's a
raptor king is a sign of good governance maybe you humans
should try move unless wait there's a rock here can i beat
up the rock here we go am i strong enough yet no i'm not
strong enough net yet Guys, there's no point.
Why am I in this rapture cave if I can't fucking beat up
the...
Beat up the rock?
Karma's coming.
What's that?
Karma?
I don't think I've ever heard of that word before.
Hoop.
Oh my god, wait, they're red scorpions.
Fresh meat?
Inbound.
First one in 10 days.
What the heck just...
all four tires punctured oh we are so unlucky
guys I think we're in the wrong part of town guys I don't
think they're Just bandits, guys.
Are we kink-shaming them, Prince?
They look fabulous.
Okay, we're gonna get these guys out.
Yay, we did it.
It's okay, they like that.
Guys, they like that.
You can tell by their outfits, they really like it.
Let's RT to do an evasive action and dodge and enemy attack.
Use RT to move in the direction to evade it.
Oh, nice.
I did that.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
If only I was full HP and I didn't waste all of that on...
Yes.
If only I didn't waste my HP on that raptor.
Don't let your guard down.
Please, will you help?
Are you, is this all he does?
Does he just cheer me on?
Okay, I definitely messed up by using my all my HP for that
one fucking raptor.
Okay, he does like two, three, a delay on the third.
Oh, that's fucking right.
I'm gonna Bowser you.
You gonna do another swing, right?
Oh, no, he's not.
then he has like one delayed oh my god look at that i know
patterns you have a gun sheriff use your
what he has a gun that's the gun right nobody's allowed to
be more evil than a fiend
Still kicking old-timer?
Yeah, thanks to you.
Never would have believed just how strong fiends are if I
hadn't seen it for myself.
Oh, please.
Those guys, they were nothing.
Yeah, they should have started off with a gun.
Then maybe I would have a problem.
By the way, Sheriff, it seems like you also have a gun.
guys this is why i should have taken the centaur i feel like
the centaur would have actually helped me in that fight we
have no choice but to walk it to talbot it's not far are you
serious oh for the i can't believe this we're not no our car
you can see it who am i gonna run oh How am I going to run
over people this time?
All right.
I can't believe it.
Oh, God.
Beasable's friends earn skill points upon leveling up.
Once you level up, open.
Okay, guys.
This might be a little bit of an issue.
Oh, I got ally skills.
They're going to actually help.
I opened up ally skill ring with LB.
Passive skills take action to...
Oh, my God.
you guys are actually gonna help power darkness he has a
vacuum diesel buff accumulates power darkness when dealing
damage to enemies or taking damage use the power to dish out
special kit skills use rb to view the skill ring menu then
press key for special attack you wish to unleash rb to
unleash a special combo in front of you oh okay i learned
learn a special attack rush how's this oh shit okay that
looks cool all right there's i have rush and then oh i can
like zoom out of the map like this okay uh all right oh yes
we fixed it i don't know how but we fixed it okay we're
gonna learn this we have new finishing move press b Jordan a
combo to keep attacking.
Alright, what about our allies?
Spoilers award chances of obtaining additional items from
defeating enemies.
Uses to insert their closing in and knock them out.
Okay.
I feel like we need more items.
I did it!
I fixed it, guys.
I did it.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
what's it like in Talbo it's a former mining town not as
well off as it once was but still the biggest town around
these parts
that's where they have the Aquanium mine isn't it or what's
left of it oh hey there is there's ores here can I beat up
the rocks I can beat up the rocks Aquanium veins tapped out
and the mines be shoved oh my god beat up the rocks.
I say as I'm mining the resources, yeah, humans.
Those goddamn humans don't know when to stop overmining.
Oh, hey, old man.
Is that the town?
Yes, that's Talbo.
Now, you two should wait here.
It'll cause havoc if people see demons wandering around
town.
I'll go on my own.
Wait, we need water and food, right?
Yeah.
Thief can just steal them for free.
Yeah, we don't have to spend money.
That is why you're here, thief.
No, that's all right.
As a sheriff, I can't condone.
But you're okay with murder?
Oh, sorry, not murder.
Um, sorry, demons don't murder, guys.
It's just injuring them.
You have the costume, right?
The costume.
Yes, of course, Prince.
I never leave home without it.
What's the costume?
What the fuck?
Is that Santa?
Oh, this is murder on my hairstyle.
What's that supposed to be?
Even if I get caught, I can just talk my way out as long as
I'm wearing this.
See ya.
I don't know.
This is not...
The bright red doesn't seem like very thief, you know, thief
camouflage-y.
The ultimate costume.
Oh, I got blood.
boomer it is a motorcycle looks like it's in good condition
we can always trust santa use this to make my escape all
right then now to get what i came here for in the first
place steal the bike do it steal the wheels these will do
nicely for provisions
For the taking.
Car jacket!
Okay, I'll grab what I need and head back.
Get food and water in town.
Alright.
If you're a spy by, you'll instantly fail the mission.
Keep your head down.
Pick up the food and water provision by holding Y.
While sneaking with RT's symbols will appear.
Okay, I need to...
Alright.
We'll grab this.
Yay, we're gonna be fed now.
Well, I should just about do it for this month's tax.
What about the water?
But we're thirsty.
Everything I work for gets taken by the Royal Army.
I like how that's like the, is it the Red Army?
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, sounds like these supplies are earmarked for the Royal
Army.
Okay, he needs to pay taxes.
Yeah, demon taxes.
It doesn't trouble me one bit.
Take everything you can get, I say.
I just, like, walk this way and then walk around.
Still haven't found enough food and water.
Better keep looking.
What do you mean, X?
Still haven't found enough food and water.
Better keep looking.
Don't worry.
I make my own.
I make my...
own pathways.
At this rate, I'll be done in no time.
Yeah, it's like the Red Ribbon Army, but like instead it's
the Royal Army instead.
Moo!
What's this cow doing?
I'll be.
Bore a row cattle.
They scared my boots off.
Looks like good eating.
All right, you're off the meat hook.
I've got places to be.
What a fuck he was watching me He was a voyeur I like how I
don't even need a sneak I can just like walk around Oh shit
wait It's alright she's not gonna turn around Don't worry
guys She was never gonna turn around anyway For a break At
times like this You borrow her such a comfort That coat is
softer than a lullaby.
Oh my god, blonde bomber!
Spino?
You have to go south.
It's hard to spot.
Surrounded by mountains.
I'm Spider Santa.
What do you want with that desolate old place?
Don't want to hear a voice.
Poma 18.
Yeah, you can tell because she's the only woman in this area
with, like, colored hair instead of black hair.
All right, where's the other one?
Oh, it's over here.
It's not like they can hear me.
I don't need a sneak.
I can just run.
Stan, I'll take the delivery to Napspace.
Nah, it's tank parts.
Way too heavy for you.
Leave it to me.
Tank parts?
Oh my god, we can steal the tanks!
I mean, they're getting parts for them, aren't they?
Man, a tank!
Just once I'd like the chance to modify one of those babies!
Quit dreaming.
With your skills, you just end up busting it.
You don't know that Treat me like a low-level monkey.
Yeah.
Beat him up I can't believe he would assume that Oh A tank
you say oh, I've got to tell the Prince I can't believe he
just assumed that she can't fix it That's so fucked up Oh,
there's a dog whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Never punished.
Let's go.
Don't need to sneak around.
I can just run.
Get this.
Some strange girl just asked me for directions to Spino.
Spino?
Where is Spino?
You know.
Where the rebel army had its base way back when.
Voice actress.
Can you make it sound like you're old?
the the old the typical generic old voice ever since the
royals stormed it decades ago what brings her there don't
know strikes me as odd though you think she could be up to
no good or something don't know what harm she could do there
if she tried Nothing of interest to us here.
Yeah, we don't need to go to Spino unless there's more gear
there.
Yay, I got food and water.
Plenty of food and water here.
Generic Old Lady Boys, O1.
That news about the tank is the most valuable piece of this
hall, though.
Yay!
Better get going.
The prince is waiting for me.
It actually does look like the Red Ribbon Army.
Even the uniforms.
Got our requisitions?
Yeah, but they seem kind of light.
Hey!
Haven't seen you around.
Yeah, it was her.
She stole all the food and water.
Wait, why are you running?
She's got something to hide.
Arrest her!
Yeah, you can tell I'm part of you guys.
I also have red
What the fuck It just has two wheels Wait what What is that
car What kind of car is that Wait It just had two wheels Did
you see that?
It just works It just works It just works A car motorcycle
Michael.
You're back already?
You work fast.
Not just fast, but talented.
I got us some invaluable information.
Apparently, the army's got tanks sitting at its base.
Whoa, tanks?
We gotta steal it.
This whole game is about a tank.
We still haven't got the tank part.
Hold on there.
that's a whole lot easier said than done hey we need some
car or other i'm not going all the way to the legendary
spring on foot hmm well we might as well check out this base
maybe we'll think of something so tank is still a rumor has
yet to be real look i saw the game cover and i was on a
tank.
So that has to be real.
Your water supply point scattered around every area.
Hold Y at a water supply point to refill your HP and water
gauge.
At refilling at a water supply point, you won't be able to
use it again for a period of time.
Okay.
So like this?
It's eastward of here.
Yay!
I'm healthy again.
Can I beat up a cow?
We'd best scout the area first.
No!
They know what I want to do!
Let me touch the cows.
Let's push on.
It's not fair.
What if I want to touch the cow?
I want to pet him.
I won't do anything else.
I wasn't going to punch him.
I swear I was not going to punch a cow.
Okay, let's go to the main objective.
No cowhugs.
Alright, so you guys want to know what it sounds like.
Yeah, I'm curious too.
Can I change it?
Oh, I can't.
Okay, oh well, guys.
I guess...
Wait, let's see.
Message size.
Let's just have it big, actually.
I feel like we should have the message size big.
I was wondering if I could change the...
Change it here for...
Oh, God, sorry, guys.
Change the change of the Japanese here.
We committed a terrible injustice against the people.
Yes, they're barely getting by as things are.
So this will have been a real blow to them.
Everything I stole was already slated to go to the army.
Yeah.
We don't care about those people.
I should have known the ruthless brutes.
They must be doing the exact same thing to every town.
what it's like taxes sorry I can't beat up those I can't
beat up those raptors we bust this down I think we could
make it through guys we have to do this together guys guys
come on guys let's do this together
guys did you not remember what I said we got bust this
together as a team like hold on there are soldiers around
seems there's a checkpoint ahead i like the tin hats i feel
like the holes just make this like make it not useful
it's not as practical with the holes in the head helmet
whoops sorry the checkpoint and do some recon sounds like a
plan let's get moving all right i want to wait where's the
where's the did it tp me wait tp'd me i was trying to mine
where's the oh it did i was like where the fuck where the
fuck were the rocks i was trying to jump on right here yeah
i can parkour this this guys here we go okay and then i
guess this is where i stop parkouring never mind this is
where the parkour stop but what can i just beat them up guys
i'm gonna go beat them up i don't need another checkpoint
guys watch this let me beat them up sheriff please i can't
punch anybody i want
They won't let me punch people.
At least I can punch this.
Why not fight them?
Yeah!
Three years ago, the whole rebel army dared to stand against
them.
But the loyal army tore them to shreds and scattered its
members to the wing.
We'll punch a bug because I'm angry.
Wow.
really that strong huh i can't wait to charge into their
base your guns don't even hurt me not even a fiend can take
them head on you don't know that i'm different like how they
went from demon to fiend like what's the difference
violence is wrong joki oh but you didn't stop me when i took
the car and ran it over bugs There's a tank.
I can't run over bugs with a tank!
That's better than a car!
Oh, I like it!
Steal it for a thief!
Do you realize what you're asking for?
Alright.
I'll do something about it.
You?
You're really sure it's okay for you to steal stuff?
If it belongs to that lousy royal army, it's fair game in my
book.
their security doesn't look very tight we should be able to
sneak in through the side entrance you've got honestly yeah
I feel like there should be more guards posted up hairspray
yeah what are you going to do with that what are you going
to do with hairspray I have an idea let's get closer don't
get spotted what's he gonna do
all right loot time look yeah look am i going the right way
i think i am oh mining time yeah oars i can't wait to
customize my tank it's gonna look so fucking cool operation
awesome oh there's no fall damage before that's my favorite
part i see
how's the sheriff gonna what's the sheriff gonna use with
hairspray
all right so what's the plan i assume you have one thief and
i will cause a little diversion out front to draw their
attention okay then what happens prince you sneak in from
the side what why me go be a decoy yourself if that's what
you want game let's go as long as i can punch you're far too
willing to let this human take the reins at every turn i'll
zip it unless you got a better idea then it's decided let's
join back up in the warehouse with the tank don't let the
soldiers spot you in there you're telling me be careful you
don't
I'll certainly try I'm the boy prince
What the fuck is he doing It's like a smoke bomb Oh they're
gonna think it's a smoke bomb
Okay that's good Say what Poison gas
Run Okay I was gonna say why are they still in it hey who
are those guys that is actually so smart looks like you
pulled it off now it's time for me to shine
who actually just said look guys the world's a mess right
now I don't think there's like school anymore in this world
I'd be surprised if they can read or write exploring
military basis be careful not to get spotted by soldiers
running or making noise will alert them so make sure to move
slowly and quietly when near soldiers okay is this
considered running
better keep a low profile till we've joined up again okay
that's not considered running okay that's good to know i
wasn't sure sneak up from behind and use why to perform a
stealth attack this will take your enemy out without
alerting others self attacks to get rid of enemies blocking
allows you to move slowly silently sorry that was RT
oh what guys he's okay guys he's gonna be okay guys I didn't
scare him to death because murder's wrong for the demons
apparently let's see I feel like if you're a soldier and you
can get you can die die from just pure fear then i don't
think you should be a soldier parkour we don't murder here
guys that's a lie we don't cross apparently or cannibalism
murder and cannibalism is like the line for the demons we
want people to die by natural causes like fear i'll keep it
fear is natural to be useful later they got the oh my god
there's a yellow That's why I knew where to go, guys.
Even the ladders are yellow.
Oh, guys, this is why I knew where to go.
I didn't even notice it.
It was just, it was subconscious.
The yellow pin was so subconscious.
It was like, I see yellow.
I go.
Even the markers are yellow.
Oh, my God.
What?
Oh, now they spot me.
After everything I did.
Oops.
They saw me.
Gotta be more careful.
No, I don't.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Alright, I'm going to scare this guy to death too.
Boo.
Fucking...
These are the worst soldiers here.
Not going to lie.
These have to be...
What the fuck?
I saw loot!
I went...
I got greedy.
I got so greedy.
Anyway, I'm coming back in.
Not gonna stop me.
There's like a guy right here.
There's like a guy right here as well.
Oh, no!
Wait, is it?
Did I loot this already?
Did I loot it?
Guys, it's a speed run, guys.
Guys.
What the fuck?
Guys, it was a speed run.
Because I already looted.
It got looted.
So I don't have to do it again, guys.
I did that on purpose.
Because I already looted that area.
So now I don't have to loot it again, guys.
Speed run.
You didn't see me, right?
No, you didn't.
Alright, nice.
Oh, nice.
There's an opening.
I did it.
I'm so good at stealth chat.
I didn't get caught.
Where's your proof?
If I get caught, I would have had a game over it.
But I did it.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
This is a fucking maze.
I'm so confused.
Hey.
Did you hear there was a big uproar even the opening is
yellow Yeah, I heard man today was just packed wasn't it
What's that what was that plot line Oh my god look guys
where do I go next I wonder Wait but there's loot guys sorry
but there's loot this is more important No get off the
ladder there's loot over there Oh they are they are sneaky
They're sneaky with this loot because it wasn't yellow.
It wasn't yellow.
They thought I didn't see it.
They tried to distract me with the yellow.
Yo, the moon is yellow.
We should go to the moon.
Alright.
Okay, let's go.
I like how slow the crawl is, though.
I don't like about it.
It's way too slow.
Did you hear?
They captured some suspicious lady.
Oh, it's blonde Boma 18.
Yeah.
Heard she had tons of maps, tools, water, but works.
Doesn't seem to be from around here.
No, I missed the loot.
Guys, guys.
Oh, it's right there!
God, why didn't it make the loot box yellow?
It's like they don't want me to get it.
That's so fucked up.
Okay, I got him.
Okay, I can't run.
All right.
Yay, does this mean there's doors open?
No, it's not.
Okay, I got B-grade steel.
All right.
I love the yellow cones.
On, okay, guys, I'm not going back.
It's their fault for not making the loot box yellow.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
They can't just put all this yellow in my face and then not
make the loot box yellow as well That's just that's just
them trying to make me not open the loot box That's on them.
That's not my fault.
I can jump this distance.
Oh my gosh, I can This is just poor design Oh Anyway, as I
was saying that was just poor level design Why did they make
that yellow?
I can't believe they made it blue.
Oh my god, it's like they don't want me to succeed.
That should be like a brighter yellow so I know it's
dangerous.
Poor soldiers, they're everywhere.
We're literally at their base.
What do you mean they're everywhere?
Where'd I go, though?
Where's the yellow?
Oh.
No.
Boo.
At least that was sort of fun.
Okay.
We gotta steal this.
I don't need to see me from here.
There's no way.
I'm so far from the distance oh he went the other way too so
that's okay all right let's see good all right uh go this
way yeah found it oh tank tank tank what's wrong with her
that little hell cat really laid into me yes she's dead set
on staying quiet no he's his self-esteem to the med tank oh
because she punched him or something i thought he was like
what about the girl i thought she like hurt him so badly
emotionally and mentally that he had to go get like
psychiatric help it'll be fine the door's locked how is she
supposed to get out of there yeah you're right hey
how's the tank it looked like it was falling oh my god it
eyes that's so cute it'll be useless before long gonna have
to call a mechanic oh my god it has eyes it's perfect so
this is a tank it's angie
sorry for the wait prince what the fuck how did they get
here so this is our new tank where do you guys come from
Four antigrath stones, big ones too.
But its mid-repair won't run like this.
So what are we gonna do?
A demon?
Woman!
You really do exist.
Hey, want to get that tank running?
Why, what's it to you?
I promise to get me out of here, and I'll fix it for you.
Oh, you're a mechanic?
We appreciate the offer, but who exactly are you?
Can't these little details wait?
Those grunts will be back any second.
Hmm, we don't have the luxury of choice here.
Prince, let's help her out.
At this point, we need that tank just to escape this base.
We just follow the yellow back.
Okay.
We don't need the tank to escape.
I mean, how the fuck did you guys get in here?
Oh my god.
Do you enjoy my fan cam of this lady?
What the fuck was that?
What was that cinematography?
Legs Were chasing after back in Talbot, aren't you?
so those goons were swapping out the transmission huh or
what they don't have a new one though gonna have to jury rig
some old ones together we're gonna mcguire the shit thanks
but this is nothing the pro cat i mean this is short guys it
was just the the princess pov guys okay he had to look up
Rao.
This here's Beelzebub and Thief.
He did etchy work before Dragon Ball?
This is the first time I've ever seen a demon face to face.
What?
It's like that one manga artist that used to do like furry
art and furry porn.
Before he became famous.
Um, is it normal for you guys to run around with humans like
this?
Absolutely not Normally I wouldn't be caught dead Sorry
Gramps Could you scooch for a sec I have a name thank you
You guys didn't know I don't remember which one There was
like a famous manga artist If you look it up you'll find it
They're already on alert for hostiles Oh it's the astro Yeah
yeah the That's a manga artist that created Astro Boy.
Yeah.
You can look up his old works.
He was really into furry art.
There we go.
That should get us moving.
Nice job.
Your ability speaks for itself.
So do I hide in the tank too?
Yeah, where does she sit?
You're not good.
know here are you it's true but he drew like naked furries
those soldiers are coming we've got to go no there's like no
crime I
forgot on purpose Forget it.
We gotta hustle.
No.
There's something very important in my things.
What the fuck is that?
Why are you planning to steal the tank off of yourself from
the start?
Bro, the helmets are so fucking stupid.
Why can't they just wear those like the red berets like
that's right you got a shot for trying to run away Yeah, I'm
a demon Every time I see their fucking helmet.
I'm just like that's so stupid Can I shoot it guys don't
worry.
It's not murder Guys see he's okay.
I told you you see he's oh he survived i shouldn't waste
that we take the wheel for a bit old man okay first step
blasting all right good work stay sharp kid the front gates
to our right head for that i'm gonna use bullets now see
look see i i didn't look they're okay they just fell down
because
wait where do i have to go do i slam it guys it's the xp
guys it's the xp can i run him over oh my god i can oh i
should boom okay sorry i was too busy running people over
can i run over these cars too oh my god i can run over the
cars too okay let's go back Don't worry, watch.
See, look!
Oh my god, it's like a fucking motor car.
Like, instead of motorcycle, it's a motor car.
Wait, that's a real car.
Um, a, a, a, a, a unicard?
No, that's a, uh, a dual car.
It's like, oh, wait, a, a dual cycle.
It's not lethal, guys.
Motor tanks are so brave.
Do not engage in it.
Infantry.
I can't help it.
I see people I shoot Just ignore them turn left.
I Can't no survivors
No survivors.
Oh shit Guys look at that I can drive without having to look
in the front Oh guys.
Oh, no Boom see the car did they explode?
Guys, don't worry, they survived.
Don't worry, they survived.
A car cycle!
They're so alive, because murder is my line.
Daisy, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tezuka-san did very, you know, before, during, and after.
Man knew what he liked, and he did.
You can do this, Prince.
i'm pretty sure um if like if they put those artwork up for
auction the amount of money they can get from that is like
actually crazy because like people who buy those are they're
fucking there are a lot of suspiciously very wealthy furries
out there i would not be surprised if like if they go up in
auction that that those type of artwork from tazuka san
would be sold for 500 grand.
Run for your lives.
Cleaned every last one of them up without a single fatality.
It would be millions.
Yeah.
I'd be bored without humans to mess with after all.
It looks like we've bought ourselves some time.
I'm convinced he was the first modern furry artist.
Without a single fatality.
Let's go.
What's that?
Prince, you should try heading over there.
Oh, I can like attach a tank gun Is this a tank part?
Looks like a main cannon if we install it in the tank, it'll
make it way stronger.
Oh my god I'm gonna absorb all the other tank parts If I
remember right the old road ahead leads to a campsite We can
install it there Which way?
We managed a simulation.
I'm going to simulate all the other tanks
We should be safe from the marching boot
Let's install the cannon you scored Great idea Let's do it
Okay, customize vehicles.
I can customize them now Uh What's this?
Oh, wait, that's stronger see that this is this is me if i
see stats numbers up numbers go up means stronger and
tutorial that's it that was a tutorial i did it what
everyone thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
the guy madding the flaming wreck that was a tank i just
yeah they're just unconscious guys number go up equals good
the enhanced firepower is welcome indeed thing is though the
transmission's at its limit after that battle suspension i
learned a lot from that tutorial guys we'll be walking soon
if nothing's done about it wait did she get shot is she okay
yeah tried my hand at any number of things during the war i
bet you it's gonna reveal that he used to be in the army and
he's like a deserter tanks i liked endless fighting i didn't
well I'm glad to have another gear head around hold up you
mean our tanks already falling apart we just got it I can
patch it up but that's a temporary fix well can't you do
something ace mechanic if we had the parts yeah and the
tools of Of course, you know, I've got a little business in
Spino.
I knew it.
There's a garage there where I should be able to get this
fixed up for you.
And then later on, she charges me.
I fucking knew it.
I'm just a cash cow to her.
She's gonna charge me for all these tank parts.
It's in the mountains to the south.
That's how they hook you in.
I think.
But don't quote me on that.
That's how they get you.
They're all the same.
Yeah, how do you know?
Someone who used to live in Spino told me all about it.
Didn't you say you have a business in Spino?
The town may be hard to find, but it actually is quite close
by.
My free trial of Tank has expired.
It's a subscription based.
Yeah, been there a few times myself.
don't know what's become of it only heard rumors well what
have we got to lose without the tank we'll never make it to
the legendary spring we should just go back no we should
just rob Spino really didn't sound like a good time if that
settled I'll get started on some makeshift repairs you guys
should get some rest Thanks.
We'll take you up on that.
Yay!
Mission complete!
We got our tank, boys!
I want to punch it.
Alright.
Wait, we don't have beds.
Do we just sleep on the rock?
Oh, yes.
Let me loot my own loot.
Press ring to choose an item.
press a to use multiple at once select item to use hold x to
reset okay wait what do i have to press again um um guys i
for uh how do i select my ring again oh there it is okay i
did it uh repair kit restores a little bit uh select item
how do i I guess like you can't customize this yet guys no I
understood I understood guys I figured it out here we go
tutorial needs a tutorial all right in just a battle tank
control type from the options other control types and
settings can be adjusted to create an experience that suits
your playstyle all right I want to see if I can upgrade oh I
can okay so flying allows you to quickly gain your Okay, I
think I'd rather have the evasion mid-jump.
What about my allies?
Can I upgrade them yet?
Increase the amount of money earned from defeating enemy.
The enemy is gifted with a bomb.
Okay, we're going to see...
We're going to get Rai or something.
Rai...
Let's deploy hairspray.
How much hairspray do you have?
Look at your hair But I would assume the thief has hairspray
our trail yet Stay vigilant and be prepared to engage
Okay, where do we go royals ahead and the bridge is raised
that it Then this roots a dead end what luck don't shape his
hair Oh my god, they have tanks!
A simulate.
Be one with the tank.
Just destroy the real and it'll come down.
My kind of plan.
Let's get to it.
Alright, here we go.
We go in.
I'm gonna simulate this tank.
Make us whole.
It's mine now.
give me your tank give me your tank no let me assimilate you
oh my god i can like scope in what the fuck okay don't worry
they're okay they're fine guys see look they're okay you
would have to lower the bridge it.
Oh, here it is.
Is that the real?
It is.
Is there loot around me?
Wait, there's tents here.
There's holes.
There must be loot.
If you see a hole, there's a loot in there.
I knew it.
It's okay.
The army don't need this loot.
They're evil.
Evil people don't need loot, guys.
It's not like these military men might be innocent and just
trying to find a place, you know, it's not because they
joined the army because it was a nice place to live and be
fed and have water rather than die in their village.
No, no, no, they're all evil guys.
Every single one of them.
Oh, here's one here.
Ooh, so much loot.
So much loot.
It might turn out to be useful later.
Anything else here?
Blue hole.
Somebody said I missed a chest here.
No, I didn't.
Oh, it's right here.
Nice.
Wait, where's my tank?
Oh, there it is.
Right in front of me.
They're all evil.
They could have just starved instead of joining the army.
You're a weird one, old man.
Loon all this to find water for other people.
Yeah, but they don't count.
They're not real.
Oh, shit.
I should have saved my fucking thing for...
Okay, I should have saved...
I should have saved the armor piercing for the actual tanks
themselves.
It's okay.
I'll be fine.
The tank will be fine.
At least that was sort of fun.
Every hole is a glute.
Exactly.
Alan.
Assimulate.
they're not the main character so they're evil
seal all their resources they don't matter yay keep it it
might turn out to be useful later yeah
I as a demon is going to cleanse all the evil in this world
so only I can be the oh so I can have the monopoly
If anybody's going to be evil around here, it's going to be
me.
The one true evil.
There are plenty of towns and villages across Sandland.
We should stop by if we come upon any.
Let's keep moving and make for Spino.
Alright, time to head to Spino.
Spino.
I don't...
But I'm sure it's a nice place.
Wait, I can shoot the tower door?
Say no more.
Say less.
Wait, there's an autopilot for tanks as well?
Technology.
Your vehicle will move forward, and so on this mode will be
disabled.
Actually destroy it?
You liars.
You liar.
I can't believe it.
This door is...
What kind of material is this door made?
made out of.
Holy fuck.
All right.
There can only be one.
Oh my god, I shoot the bird!
What would you do if you ran into a tough enemy?
Shoot the bird!
Oh my god!
I just shoot the bird!
Don't worry.
Look, he's okay.
Look, see, he's okay.
Whoa, there's a scorpion!
Friendly, bye.
It just works.
I could shoot the bird!
10 out of 10.
Could you beat any router?
Wait, am I driving backwards?
That's okay.
This is how you drive now What's the last time you shower?
Oh my god, look at them.
It's so cute guys Guys look how cute this is.
They're having a moment on people's B.O
I'm not a bad person right?
Oh my god, loot!
Spare them!
They're like, my child!
Don't worry.
You can live...
Don't worry, you'll see your child in heaven.
My turn out to be useful.
Oh my god, there's mines!
There's ores here.
What are mine?
Loot, loot, loot, loot.
Loot.
And then...
I punched the ores.
I'm just helping them reunite exactly You want that mom to
live her rest of her life In the grief and depression I was
doing a good thing even though I might have caused her
depression I was putting her out of her misery Oh my god I
hit it I hit this Nice Look loot is important chat It might
be useful later okay i'm gonna use up all the ammo so i can
reload i think that's the worst part the reload like
manually you get to use all the ammo to reload can't believe
it's only two xp i think they try to prevent you from
killing the wildlife because they don't give you any xp chat
don't justify your sins
well there's a weird place Oh, I can!
How do I reload?
What's that?
King army.
Who's that?
Plains have been outlawed by royal decree.
There shouldn't be a single one left in the world.
Why planes?
Wait, what?
Why did they outlaw planes?
It stopped.
What should we do?
Stay hidden.
I'll handle this.
Where did he grab the helmet?
Oh my god.
Look at his hair.
That's the guy that definitely used hairspray.
Do you read me?
Is your transmitter broken 104?
I like how it's like, is your transmitter broken?
And then like, how would I...
Okay, like...
If it's broken, I won't be able to hear that.
What the fuck?
I love that
little like eyelash detail that like he always does for his
characters when they're like when they're like evil but
they're like flamboyant evil the little eyeliner and then
the eyelash at the bottom I love that character trait that
he does we need to hide take cover under
it just works guys is this really going to work let's just
see how things play out nap space reports someone has stolen
a tank number one zero four the perpetrator has not been
spotted but is capable of handling a tank I repeat nap space
turn us around quickly right now crooked to hamburger thinks
he can fool general Ari does he we got to change the numbers
on our tank, guys.
How did they know?
Uncover the tank.
We have to find.
I told you to call in Prince Beelzebub.
I'll take them out myself.
It's okay.
I'm going to shoot the plane.
I have so much ammo.
What does it do?
Shoot back?
Watch this.
Head for the high ground.
Wait, the high ground?
No!
What?
What do you mean?
I can't fucking pull up!
Oh my god, he's right.
He's right.
They won't be able to hurt us without their machine gun.
Take that down first.
Which one?
There?
Fire!
I got it.
We're going to counterattack.
Hide behind those rocks.
You can boost to avoid attacks.
Just make sure to watch out for overheating.
Okay, I got you.
I got you, sir.
Try slipping behind a rock to get the leeway to reload
safely.
Don't worry, sir.
I got you.
I'm hiding.
Oh!
How do you reload?
There's no reload button.
There's literally no reload.
I felt like I was lying to you about reload.
High ground.
If hitting the machine gun's too chancy, keep aiming for the
tank.
Okay, yeah, I know you can do this.
B is not reload.
It's the swap car.
Oh It's okay.
I'm in the blind spot Look at the top.
Oh my god.
There's a top right?
Oh
Guys guys did you guys know top right there's instructions
over there Did you did you guys know that did you see did
you see it?
Did you see it?
i'm learning guys i'm learning oh god oh god look i can just
hide behind here a blind spot he's so confused guys look
look at that fool he's so confused oh no oh no oh no oh no
he doesn't know where i am god we gotta head to high ground
we have to head to high ground okay you know what i don't
even need a i don't need to destroy the machine gun i can
literally just shoot it dead point thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you donkia's best when she's illiterate
she's perfect illiterate and dumb but we can drop bombs
right on their heads not good they're trying to bomb us
enemies course and cut them off bombs away it's only a
matter of time before nothing's left of us but a smoking
crater see that's a water tank no the free water lift the
front end and try to shoot straight up it's no good even at
max output we still weigh 1562 kilos how do you know that up
right never ask a tank how much it weighs guys how do you
think you're doing get back in the tank now what you think
my help's gonna make it heavier oh ship
that's right prince b's above keep pushing
What if I just stop?
What if, like, would I crush my allies?
What if, like, I don't do it?
Oh, nothing happens.
Okay, there's no consequences for my actions.
I just thought it'd be funny if there was a game over screen
where the tank just crushes them.
Incredible.
I can't believe it.
They're doing it.
Good.
We're in position.
Fire.
Impossible.
punished quick assimilate become one with the tank with the
mother tank thanks prince thief we managed to pull through
that somehow we did odd though that plane seemed to be
transporting a massive amount of if that's true the king's
water supply must be in the direction it came from meaning
that it must also lie to the south of here yeah where did
they grab all that water they know where the spring is you
telling me this legendary spring we've been looking for all
this time is really the king's water supply if that's true
doesn't that mean whole journey's been for nothing I mean
that's not nothing we just we're just gonna raid the camp
wait the general's in there at this point we've got to see
it through interrogate him he's not dead because nobody dies
in this game guys remember that don't look now but our tanks
taken even more damage in the last battle just kill the king
uh oh we better get to that town fast It's called Spino.
Yeah, back.
Come on.
Let's go.
Something's on the ground near the tank.
Near my tank.
Where?
All right.
Come on, guys.
Let's go.
It's time to simulate.
Assimulate.
Absorb for the mother tank.
Where is the people at?
Because they're not dead, right?
They're alive, right?
What happened to the people?
Guys, did you know like our B was reload this entire time?
For the good of the country, we want to put an end to the
water shortage.
Oh, I can destroy the rocks now!
You know, I realize.
We are.
Once we find that spring, I'm gonna take a leak in it.
Oh, my God.
Oh, he is.
No, he is evil.
Look, it wouldn't matter.
There's animals already in the drinking water.
So, like, technically the animals already peed in the
springs.
So, adding my peed.
All I'm saying is it wouldn't make that much of a
difference.
Okay, let's see.
We got to do our allies stuff.
uh i want more money sounds about right all i'm saying is
that it wouldn't make that much of a difference oh heavy
machine gun damage up okay but damage is higher so that
means it's better here we go all
right look i'm just saying we're trying the ph levels are
too low so i'm upping the ph levels might lead us to a
useful location like a Is someone talking?
Who's talking?
Ah, forgot to turn off the radio.
Wait, I can turn on the radio?
Wait,
I can turn on the radio?
Wait, wait.
Who's Zayu?
Oh, Supreme Commander Zayu.
Is that old Kodger still?
Wow, Rao.
That's suspicious.
How do you know about the Supreme Commander?
That seems all too clear, my.
We can safely assume that those vermin are heading oh my
god, it is mad max
Oh my god, this is mad max Meanwhile, we'll use the media to
root them out of their little hidey hole And exterminate
them It's like, what if Frieza's little, like, ball vehicle
thing was just a person Sir, yes, sir Those renegades won't
get past me Honestly, who steals a tank?
Like, anybody?
I'd steal a tank?
It's a fucking tank!
Looks like my glory actually has a spine for once Monster
Envy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Toriyama loves old geesers as villains.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who wouldn't?
You wouldn't download a tank, would you?
Who's going to change crappy's typing?
Only one way to find out.
Let's head south.
All right.
It's getting dangerous.
Oh, I love danger.
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
Wait, can I...
Whoa, free loot!
I can't believe they would just leave the loot there.
Out in the open, just for me.
What's this?
Oh, there's a...
There's lore.
Oh my god, it's somebody's like...
It's somebody's loot.
to come back here right but they don't need to come back
here anymore thanks for oh my god ben died thank you thanks
for playing zen land assimilate exactly all tanks got
assimilated into the mother tank can i drive off this oh my
god there's no fall damage there's fall damage guys i don't
know you know this guys but there's fall damage
okay am i going the right way i'm lost already oh no after
driving oh this way after driving off the cliff i had i
don't know where i'm heading all right this way i think all
right i learned that there was indeed a fall damage and now
i do not have the repair thing anymore are there royal army
soldiers all over sandland there's even a bunch near our
village look just See the bridge there?
Spino is right beyond it.
Is that Spino?
Spino, huh?
Oh, that was...
Okay, I thought that was the village.
Guys, I knew there was a barrier.
Guys, I shot because I knew there was a barrier.
Spino's just on the other side of these doors.
Come on, let's go in already.
I'm dying to see the sights in a whole new town.
Oh my god, new town!
I was testing the defenses!
Exactly!
Damn, they have good defenses, guys!
No wonder the rebel army is okay.
They're still alive.
It's dokey proof.
So this is Spino?
I heard the rumors, but this place is even more run down
than I'd imagined.
It's little better than a ghost town.
Can we really repair our tank here?
Why is there no one living in this town?
The defenses were so good.
I literally shot a fucking missile.
So I was told.
My visitors are rare around these parts.
Are you folks travelers?
Yes.
Oh my god, is he also old?
I'm this town's mayor now.
I know you just got here But I'm afraid that I'm going to
have to ask you to leave what why May I at least ask why
yeah What did I do I didn't shoot your gate I swear we can't
welcome outsiders Hold on a minute mayor Tor what did I do
wrong trouble i swear yeah i swear she shot the gate dokey
no it wasn't me there's no cameras to prove anything you
know who i am young lady i have alibi yes i've uh only heard
about you from longgo though longgo who's longgo longgo i
know only one person by that name the same one no doubt he
wanted me to give you this letter take a look let's see then
why this is the symbol of the rebel army so the old war
horse is still kicking is he who the fuck is long ago trust
me now
why does the merchant sound like the guy from look like in
the world of voice acting there's like 10 people you're free
to use it as you see fit thank you
you worked some magic back there the man who raised me is an
old friend of the mayors that's all what was in the letter
just a request to allow me to use the garage and tinker
around to my ticking hearts content and why exactly did you
need to risk life and limb to use this specific garage well
I mean just look at I mean like yeah like this garage it
literally has arms coming from the ceiling it's been put
through But it's well maintained The control console's
working the power arm moves And a whole smorgasbord of spare
parts and tools smorgasbord You won't see a full-service pit
stop nearly as good as this anywhere outside the army I
suppose she's right But what Enough with the chit-chat.
Can you fix our tank or not?
No.
What if she just says no?
Also, I pinned the message from Bandai.
I'm going to have my egos.
Guys, you might see my ego, like, from the moon for, like,
the next month, guys.
How about you guys take a stroll around the block?
Hmm.
All right.
We'll leave you to it, then.
We might as well mingle with the locals for a bit.
We're gonna talk to children?
Hello, kid.
It's possible that they'll know a route south or what the
army's up to.
Come on, let's go!
Child.
Do you have money?
Demon?
Chill out.
I'm not gonna eat you or anything.
You're not?
Glad you're one of the nice ones.
nice ones what do the evil ones do because apparently we're
not allowed to kill so like what's the worst i can do at
this point like far from it you're talking to the fiend
prince the yelzebub oh i see glad you're a nice prince yeah
whatever how do you like spino a great place huh yeah a
great big dump I'll admit, it's seen better days.
Ages ago, the Royal Army attacked the town.
That's how it ended up like this.
But my hard work's gonna put Spino on the map.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
You're a kid.
Yeah, wait, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
With all the assimilation happening, I expect this to become
the cell saga.
Also, do you know about Toriyama's Q Vault?
He designed a real car.
Wait, he made a real car?
didn't know that as much as your work ethic he has plans
you're five years old child what are you gonna do what is
this child gonna do okay oh hey old lady talk to me i'm
important oh okay
See, she talked to me.
Oh, she doesn't even have voice acting.
Like, oh, what the fuck?
That old lady has voice acting and she doesn't?
Wait, they all say hello there.
You have the same voice as the other old lady.
Okay, at least we know it's not her.
It's not just her.
Wait, he's me!
Just like me!
The children?
We're not crooks.
You have nothing to fear from us.
Um, hello?
We're demons?
You should absolutely fear us.
We're demons.
Prince, that's not helping.
Keep quiet for a moment.
Sorry for frightening you.
We merely want to ask you something.
Oh?
What?
We're headed south.
No of a safe route we can take.
I don't have good news for you.
What?
Why not?
The royal army has blockaded off all routes headed south of
here.
No getting past them.
And there's no way around?
Only if you can make it across the East Valley There's no
bridge though It collapsed a short while ago I'll make my
own bridge If I shoot enough rocks on the side It'll start
piling up on the ground That like a bridge will show up You
think about it And you keep throwing rocks In the pit The
rocks will eventually pile up into a bridge He knows these
parts better than me old guy over there it's true it's
called engineering engineers will vouch for me right
engineers in chat am I right and there's only one answer
very true master class of terraforming I like how all the
kids have like voice acting scare you do I good You're not
scary.
You're adorable.
Oh, I'm cute.
Quite the compliment, huh, Prince?
You're adorable, too, Mr. Take that back.
No one's scarier than me.
Bro, you're old.
Looks like we're in the same boat.
Well, people aren't scary.
You just push them.
And then there'll be...
And then, like...
And then there'll be a problem.
Hey.
We need to go south.
And then you gotta make sure you don't get sued.
Fix the bridge for us, would you?
How would I do that?
Look at the state of this town.
We have neither the people nor the resources to fix the
bridge.
Hmm, in that case, our only option is to penetrate the
blockade.
That's what I'm saying.
They're not scary.
Because, like, they're old.
They're weak.
Count me out.
do we have why are you so determined to travel south we're
hoping to find a spring and end the water shortage is that
there's like no muscle left in them but I don't see how
you'd be able to cross that ravine without a bot that excels
at jumping a jumping bot where can we get a jumping bot
there are mentions of them in the rebel army's old files but
i suppose you need a real jump bot not records of one then
again that girl with you seem to know her way around
machines should we try to pick her brain on this matter good
idea if anyone will know it's her all right so we just had
to talk oh my god we're breaking this home oh i can't punch
his home wait that's your home can i steal your water oh i
Oh, it's just a diary.
Lango's diary.
Oh, it's lore.
Wait, do I have skill points?
I don't.
How do I look at lore?
Where the fuck is the lore?
Oh, we're not looking at the lore.
Guys, it might look like we're never gonna look at lore.
That's okay.
We never wanted to read anyway, I guess.
wait oh i forgot to talk to her for a quest or for items
okay what is health drink repair kit fire power kit b grade
stool uh steel uh sharp shock absorbing rubber i don't need
any of that i have enough loot all right it's okay we can't
read anyway guys it's okay we never we don't finally i can
pretend I don't have to pretend that I can read thank God
who's that is that demon or a cat it's a cat she has paws he
looks like a demon he has paws seen this guy before thief
nope can't say I have oh just because he's a demon You
assume that just because he's a demon he knows all the other
demons.
Wow Stands to reason there would be entire types even I
don't know about that's fucked up huh, maybe we found a new
friend then
What the fuck is that Where's his nose?
Where the fuck is his nose?
Hey, who are you?
Don't beat me!
It's like, what if Majin Boo...
What if Majin Boo was really into cats?
Okay, that doesn't explain much.
Cat Krillin.
Whoa, a demon?
I'm not a demon.
Like I told you.
I'm catish.
Wait, then what are you?
So, a cat-like thing.
Why were you sleeping here?
Want to know?
Then hand over something rare.
Meow Jin Boo.
Wait, that's good.
It's Meow Jin Boo.
Like this ancient coin.
You can usually find him in ruins.
Is that fucking cat?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, uh, thanks.
What's that?
You want to trade this right back to me for something good,
you say?
Oh, yeah, of course.
Wait, free loot.
Well, if you insist, take this storage capsule in exchange.
A storage capsule.
I can hold more gear.
This beauty right here can shrink even the biggest fuck down
to pocket size.
Oh, it's capsules!
something good in the ruins it's all connected i'll give you
something even better capsule court see ya oh my god this is
like a thousand like what the fuck where did he go holy shit
his people need him oh my god it's like a thousand years
after the earth died after the earth became sandland we
never so much as learned why he was sleeping there Code.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ma!
There's a weird fucking cat outside.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everything's connected.
It'll be incredibly useful down the road.
The Toriyama multiverse.
Luckily.
Technically there is.
Because Dr. Slump and Dragon Ball Z had a crossover.
Well, it's mine.
So, handoff.
So there is a multiverse.
They all...
Wouldn't dream of swiping The cinematic universe.
The Toriyama cinematic universe is real.
Now she'll be able to stand a little...
TCU!
Like I said, Ace Mechanic.
Just bring her in if she breaks again.
What about building us something new from scratch?
Look, I may be good.
But a tank's way too complicated to build from square one
No, not a tank a bot one that can jump Come again Oh my god,
my tank's gonna be able to jump Okay, I get it Solid plan
appeals to the gearhead in me Does that mean you think you
can do it?
How the fuck is this a jump probably?
like trying to figure out a core frame that is a core frame
what's that a core frame yeah can you speak can you rephrase
that in apex terms remember how i said i can't build a tank
from scratch that's because i don't have and can't build its
most complex inner workings jump bot same deal i need the
core parts to get started well that's a bummer We don't have
a core frame.
Not yet.
Just gotta find another tank to simulate.
Surely there's something we can do.
Well, we might be able to acquire one at a junker's market.
A junker's market.
A junker's market?
Great idea.
Is one nearby?
I wouldn't know.
Asking Mayor Tor might be the quickest way to find out.
All right.
She just needs an octane pad.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for explaining it in Apex terms, guys.
It was really helpful.
It's so weird whenever there's like a little, like, I can't
move before, like, the quest thing goes, like, quest
complete.
So every time that little, like, pause, I'm like, why can't
I move?
Is my game bugged?
You can use a garage.
There you can create, upgrade, and switch vehicle parts, as
well as choose which vehicle to use.
Wait, I can use more than one vehicle.
Spindle will grow as you complete side quests gaining you
build.
Oh my god.
It's like animal crossing, too The more I do to oh my god,
it's like it's like anime fallout Oh my god, this game has
everything anime fallout 4 um anime mad max This game has
everything Uh gaining new buildings and inhabitants as you
go along you might find new stores and new products and
existing stores completing side quests is most certainly to
your benefit uh anime world of tanks and anime world thunder
it has everything all right let me know if you want to just
bring me the material i'll have it souped up and raring to
go does she just live here wait she's not Follow me
anywhere.
No, no more.
What the fuck?
We need like, at least like one female in this team.
Guys, this is getting it.
There's too many guys here.
We need to diversify.
It's like, it's like those like, like those like, like shows
where there's always like the one, the one female to make
sure, to make sure the team has everybody.
It's just too old guys!
Too many old people!
Someone please pick female.
Is there a junker's market around here?
I wouldn't say it's nearby exactly, but there actually is a
fairly large one in the area.
It's right at the foot of the cliff the Lysaw battleship
juts out from.
Can't miss it.
Sweet!
Let's get going already!
Oh wait, she's back?
What the fuck?
Wait!
Oh my god!
She didn't leave!
Thank God!
Now this team is balanced.
This team is balanced now.
Think of it like a treasure hunt.
Doesn't that get you excited?
I guess.
But then it's decided.
I call first dibs!
Yay!
This is the team, guys.
Oh, thank God.
We're like, we're like chipping down rescue rangers!
Oh, but Wait, where did she go?
She just wants to shop.
She's only here to shop.
The dream team.
Out of the Chip and Dale Rescue Rangers.
This is basically it.
What a team.
I'm Chip.
He's Dale because we're both the same height.
He's the...
I forgot the name.
The guy with the funky...
Because he has a mustache too!
He also has a mustache!
Oh my god!
We're literally, and then, and then, she's the, the female
one!
She's, he's launch padded.
Who's the fly?
The fly's the tank.
That's who's the fly.
The fly's the tank, guys.
gadget yeah gadget
all right so i can uh look the only people i remember in the
chippendale rescue range like the names the only names i
remember from the chippendale rescue rangers was chippendale
because they were because it's chippendale i really don't
know any of the other names i just remember the female rat
the rat with the fucking mustache and the fly
literally the title there was a fat cat oh yeah there was a
fat cat because he was fat and was a cat all right capsule
men you choose vehicle uh okay the vehicle inside a capsule
can be charged change that cap i only have one tank though
dangerous enemies on maps such as monsters will attack your
enemies or or halos so watch out okay uh how do you forget
about a lord and savior gadget that created that one cult oh
my god yeah there was there's a Russian cult surrounded
surrounded about the the female rat gadget oh my god I'm
gonna steal the I'm gonna GTA this dinosaur
okay let's see autopilot jump intimidate i can intimidate
monsters won't attack when you're riding raptor so you can
explore safe how your raptor will run away my raptor's gonna
run away i'm gtaing right now okay intimidate oh that's cool
i don't like those little sack things on the back of its
tail because usually those sack things on the back of its
tails for like actual real life animals grand theft i know
yeah i'm i'm gtd right now Grand Theft Dano Okay For biology
Biology facts Usually when there's a huge sack Behind like
for the animal It is used for like Um It is used for For
attracting the females What the fuck
Okay Um Cool Thank you Dano But it's usually used for like
you know mating purposes it's typical animal biology just
take a look over there where that thing's huge what is it he
saw battleship it's this one's first sitting i'll have to
report it's where the pheromones come out don't you what the
fuck is that my father we're through is that another dino oh
my god guys we're gonna we're what is that is that dino it's
a traveler oh my god can my dino my dino needs a girlfriend
is it okay we do an arranged marriage between our dino's
hello oh yeah that this one has to be feet look it's perfect
you can tell You can tell that dino is female because my
dino is bigger.
Oh my god, what if we just robbed this guy?
Our dino now.
Okay.
Let's see whether this way.
Talk to that merchant?
All right.
It fills your vision.
I want to talk to you.
Raptors and what?
Only proud the road to the battleship.
I've been losing sleep worrying about them getting my cargo.
Is that it?
Dark energy.
Power of darkness.
What the fuck is power of darkness?
Can I, like, attack them?
Hello, friend?
Friend.
Hey.
Hey, the...
He's not looking.
You want to come with us?
she's busy with the kids you want to come with us
all right let's see where do we go okay we go this way 2000
that's so far but she's so fast though my dino is really
fast hey baby girl see what is the jump look like oh my god
loot it's what you call people who make a living finding oh
i can loot here too they tend to be roughnecks so don't go
picking hey there hey baby girl
i show you my thermos
Please respond.
I just can't.
Turkey, please.
What?
Turkey.
What did I do?
The ocean's Right outside of sandland.
Can I farm with this?
Oh, I can farm with my dino.
It's so convenient I like how like I like how they're just
following me from the back too I don't show you my tail
bulb, please.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I didn't do anything wrong.
I like how I think my favorite part is that even though I'm
on the dino, they have to I think I think that's the
funniest part they have to like they don't get any type of
transportation they gotta follow me Let's see I'll go to a
radio tower We'll parkour Dino parkour let's go There's like
something here wait is that town over there There's like so
much Yeah
wait no don't shoot my guy don't shoot him okay i'm gonna
park you right here i don't want to lose you okay you're
gonna stay here stay here okay stay here items inside them
that could be i need the loot i can't lose the dino it's
actually so convenient wait is that missile oh my god he has
a fucking missile it's fine i'm stronger He can't aim.
They're like Star Troopers or Storm Troopers.
Yeah.
No, don't run away.
No, I parked him.
I parked the Raptor, guys.
There's no way.
No!
Don't say that!
Use materials to prepare.
Once repaired, Tyler will provide you with the map of the
icon.
Can I?
Can I, though?
I parked the Raptor.
I
There's no way There's no way We had like a bond There's no
way The raptor and I had a bond Where did he go?
No!
I parked you in everything!
What?
Guys, I got dino jacked!
There's no way he would never run away Someone jacked my
dino I know.
There's been a robbery.
Somebody jacked my dino.
He went home.
I've been dino jacked.
This is serious.
Crime is not a joke.
According to the map.
this area is near the center of sandland someone gtaed the
dino i gtaed i can't believe it i can't believe it the steep
cliffs make traveling north or south of here a serious
challenge i can't believe someone downloaded my dino let's
see where do i go i'm lost now oh my god i've been trying to
get to this cave oh no guys i think i'm a little lost I'm so
sad, guys.
I'm so sad.
We got to file.
We got to call the cops.
We got to file a police report.
This is important.
My fucking car.
Oh, God.
Whoa.
Here we go.
I'm so sad.
How...
am i going to cope this is not the same oh my god wait a
simulate it's time for a simulation it's a simulation time
all right nice guys it's okay it exploded but they'll be
okay you gotta remember there's no fatalities here
a simulate oh he found money Nice.
All right.
There has to be loot in here.
Consume the metal.
Return to the mother tank.
All right.
Loot.
Yeah, loot.
According to the map, this area is near the center of
Sandland.
This is the center?
So we can reach a bunch of places from here, huh?
Wait, where did my tank go?
Did I got fucking GTT'd?
The steep cliffs make traveling to the north or south?
of here a serious challenge pretty inconvenient for a
central hub i almost got i can't believe it i almost got
grand theft tank but it's okay i have more capsules but if
there's a whole junkers market right below oh my god look
surely those junkers have long since stripped it of anything
valuable my loot now
cost us a pretty penny.
It's okay, guys.
I've been a loot goblin.
We have so much loot.
We're so rich now.
Oh, no, I have to reload.
Don't worry.
We're going to kill some scorpions.
This has to be enough money.
Oh my God, there's more loot.
Let's go into this suspiciously dark cave.
Let's not.
Get in the tank!
Get in the tank, B's above!
Okay.
It's okay.
He's not gonna slap me while I bring out the tank, right?
Oh!
Oh, he definitely slapped me.
Get in the pocket tank.
Here we go.
Boom.
There we go.
Now I can...
Now I can loot the suspiciously dark cave.
Another loot page.
Man, I sure wish I could read.
Look.
We need to keep our bearings passing between the cliffs.
It's easy to lose this massive direction on these windy
roads.
If you get lost, be sure to check the map.
Guys, I know how to read the map.
I might be illiterate, but I can look at picture books.
Do I need to drink water?
Nah, we don't need to stay hydrated.
Alright, we gotta...
Okay, let's kill these scorpions for more loot.
And then we'll run over the babies.
Okay, we'll attempt to run over the babies.
week is there more loot over here can i no oh it's like too
far up okay we're gonna go this way i assume five we're
almost there jonathan thank you for the super chat thank you
thank wait what's up here don't worry i'm gonna help you it
really is huge my job here is done And get over here.
Now look what's become of such technology.
How the fuck did I get?
Oh, I get up from here.
You truly are fools.
What a shame.
I wish I could see it airborne.
I did it.
I helped.
Whoa!
There's ruins here?
Considering how conspicuous they are.
Throughout your travels, you encounter people attacked by
monsters or gangs.
Save them and you're...
I love getting rewarded for my efforts.
Aren't you a killjoy?
Alright.
Hey, yeah.
When it comes to finding the treasure inside it.
Right, old man?
My fees aren't cheap.
Assuming there's treasure to be found.
Josie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Toki.
With all the sand, do you find it coarse, rough, and
irritating?
Does it get everywhere?
I fucking hate sand.
I say yes.
I play sand land.
Wait, what's my...
Did he give me anything?
What did he give me?
what the fuck i don't do good things for free there's a
price for everything oh my god two bullets and he's dead
that has to be a baby scammed i can't believe it i got
scammed you should have given me his bag
what's this oh what's this ruins there's so many baby
scorpions here Or beat up a bug.
Holy shit.
Can I summon a fucking tank here?
Oh my god!
Professor...
There's no Professor Oki to stop me.
Oh my god.
I can summon a tank in stores.
Holy shit.
I can run my...
tank indoors guys right outside of sandland isn't it can't
we get water from there oh no guys my tank's a little thick
i choose you take my tank was a little thick guys surrounded
by a vast desert and steep cliffs dang yes we really do need
a water force all right okay uh Nice.
Oh, no wonder I need a tank down here.
I was supposed to bring a tank down here to blast that.
Hello?
Whoa, is this lore?
Is this demon ruins?
What's this?
Where do I go?
Oh, there's a door here.
Wait, is there...
Are those, like, beautiful old ancient ruins?
Let me destroy it.
Sorry, I got a little British there.
for a sec.
I'm not that noble.
Oh, there's a door here.
If we don't help each other.
I guess.
All right.
We go this way.
Oh!
I don't like that.
I don't like those bugs.
The ones with like million the millipedes.
Ugh.
I have filled that museum.
That got too detailed.
What did I get?
I got an ancient gold.
Oh, I got the gold coin for the cat.
For Meow Jin Boo.
Okay.
I guess that's what the coins are for.
What the ruins are for.
I bet they've got loads of loot in there.
But somehow I doubt they'll take kindly to intruders.
If I don't look at them, they don't exist.
shock you out of it please at least try to be sneaky about
it oh millipede's incentive ah i hate it i hate it i hate
them especially like they can be like like really big too
all right nice okay bring out the tank
okay dead poor thank you for the super chat thank you Thank
you.
Feet froze love millipedes.
You know, I saw a short that's saying that like the Prince
Charming in Cinderella is a feet guy.
Because who else would go like door to door for like
thousands of hundreds of towns trying to find his like with
just a glass slipper.
Just think about that.
It makes sense, guys.
It makes sense.
He's 100% a feet guy.
Hey, guys.
I'm here for the jump bot.
Hello.
Oh, you look like a bad guy.
It's romantic, not a...
Sure.
You can tell yourself that.
We get what we came for.
Yeah, I've heard that one before.
And he somehow found the room.
real person with the same feet size that he knew 100% yeah
after checking hundreds of people she was literally the only
one that had the same foot size for the glass slipper out of
every how would he know
oh my god there's another title oh my god there's another
dino for me to gtd all right let's see i think i can like
customize my vehicle right i have like chips oh i need it
locked it's like locked oh i need to like unlock it i feel
like i don't need any of these power-ups not gonna lie hello
uh workshop I have so many mats.
I don't need to buy anything.
Free dino.
Look, somebody stole my dino.
So I have the right to steal somebody else's dino.
It's a...
It's just a demon is talking to me.
It's just the cycle of life.
No, no.
What should I do?
It's the end for me.
I don't want to die.
Dino for dino.
take it forward the heck are you going on about no one's
trying to kill you but my granny told me I die if a demon
spoke to me and why are you still yeah why are you still
alive equivalent exchange exactly you're right that that is
strange you are a demon right enough of this nonsense give
us the jump up parts already I don't have anything like that
you don't then tell us who Yeah, who has it?
So I can beat them up.
But I can't just keep talking to demons like this.
Why not?
Get to the point.
If you're scared of my words, you don't want to see what my
fists can see.
Yeah.
I punched a lot of baby dinosaurs.
And I felt nothing.
I have empathy, guys.
I swear.
He always has the latest info.
Let's go pay him a visit.
All right.
I'll go pay him a visit.
Do you have stuff behind here that I can rob?
I mean, borrow?
Wow, look at all these gems.
Gems?
Can I look around a bit?
Sure, but don't get lost.
Oh my god, he's like the dad in the team.
I told you, it's just like chipping down rescue rangers.
He's just like him.
this hunter is this a side quest oh you earn rewards by for
taking on bounty hunt requests and reporting back once you
completed them okay i'm gonna accept that diamonds boss oh
god it's it's those fetish freaks again it's a bdsm gear
guys and then abandoned oh my god it's another tank to
assimilate oh my god look at that oh it reminds me of the
planes with the angry faces We're gonna accept all of them.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
No, I'm gonna accept all of them.
They're all gonna die.
I mean, uh, pass out.
Tricky jumper.
Oh, is this a jumper?
Oh, that's what the jumper is gonna look like?
No!
What if I wanna kill?
I can't take any more?
I wanna be a bounty hunter!
Bro, screw fucking finding water for people.
That's something I've never laid eyes on.
Are you four?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What's a woman?
What is that supposed to mean?
Hey, I'm the one you're supposed to be surprised by.
Apparently, junkers consider her to be a rarer.
So, uh, What are you looking for?
Could it be?
The female?
You know where we can find a core frame for a jump bot Oh so
You're here on business I mean Sure I know where to find
them But it'll cost you After all You gotta take a shot It's
even rare than demons apparently Negotiate Negotiate Don't
worry I have a woman here to negotiate for me think money
duh sorry but our funds are limited can't you just tell us
tell us what you want maybe that generous young lady there
could foot the bill i'm just as broke as the rest of you
just give him a small date whoa whoa hey i'm a sheriff Whoa!
I said that as a joke, bro!
What?
No, no.
I just want to hear her say, please, four.
What the fuck?
Well, Anne, you heard him.
Your call.
That's a pretty fair trade.
Fine.
What?
That's all he wants?
Bro, it ain't bro.
Please, four, six.
Please, dragoons.
Yep, that'll do.
That fake wannabe junkers came around.
No manners at all.
They found this jump bot on board the Lysaw battleship.
Sheep.
You're all sheep.
You're just like him.
Watch this out and hog all the parts on the ship ever since.
Sure, finders, keepers is something of a way of life among
junkers.
Fudge shop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doug.
Give us birthday today.
Haven't chosen a cake yet, so I'm asking you to pick a
flavor.
The wilder, the better, since I've had sushi cake last year.
Get green tea.
Green tea cake.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday
dear Fudge, happy birthday to you, yeah, or ice cream, no
ice cream cake, get ice cream cake, ice cream cake is so
much better.
Yelza, that's what I'm talking about.
That's a dead point, thank you for the super chat, thank
you, thank you.
Yep.
I can't believe it, he's in my chat too.
Oh my god.
Jump bot for ourselves, if we clobber them.
If you clobber them, then fine, sure.
talk thank you with a super chat thank you thank you not
even a true sim didn't ask for a few things
the entrance to the ship is through the cave up ahead okay i
gotta go through there i imagine that bouncing schmucks
already made it pretty far inside go get him by the way miss
could you oh my god he's hooked guys he's hooked.
He's going to tier 10 sub to her.
Oh my god, it's too late.
It's too late.
He's going to find out what's her YouTube account.
She's going to be his Oshi forever now.
Alright, well, okay, how far is this?
Okay, 190.
Okay, I'm going to grab this, grab these items, and then
we'll go back and steal that dinosaur.
i'm gonna gtd it okay grab this and then all right my full
hp now does that heal my tank as well does drinking water
heal my tank can i select oh my gosh okay i'm going back
it's time to gtd it clock thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you damn this just got me thinking about how
people about people donate for a yeah that line that line
right you know the deal clock thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you JP thank you with the super chat thank
you thank you he's gonna find her only tanks no I can't GT
bro what the fuck no dinos no and then he ran off no dinos
allowed sir this is dino cyst me thank you for the 10 get
the ships thank you thank you i can't believe it they hate
dinosaurs it's time it's time to get rid of a get rid of a
village what'd you expect bad guys no oh my god he's the
chosen one just you win i'm gonna be the biggest baddest
demon ever Let's see.
Oh, they're fine.
They're fine, guys.
Battle ship cape.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's loot.
Can I, like, loot it from here?
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
I don't have to get off my tank.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
It's not a crime if they deserve it.
They scared my...
They wouldn't let me have my...
idols looks like this cave leads straight to the lisa
battleship wait is that the part that the junkers have
cobbled together a convenient route between the market and
battleship oh here it is there it is but how do i no dino
for you that's so up oh i have to jump i have to parkour
guys i found the yellow i found the fucking yellow it's
always the yellow all right this way this way I like how
like the sound is I like the sound design for this game like
even in the case you can tell like we're in the caves with
the immersion
find all sorts of treasure hidden around the world use that
these skills leave radar to make locating treasure easier
but I don't treasure.
As I can tell, neatness is an alien concept to junkers.
Spood booster chip.
Oh, I found like a booster chip.
Oh, that's nice.
Roku, thank you for the gifted chips.
Thank you.
The yellow paint cave.
My favorite.
My favorite type of cave.
I don't need ladders.
I can parkour.
Wait, which way do I go?
Oh, this has to be... Okay, this is the lore.
maybe there's loot here i knew it cave is huge i knew it i'm
a real gamer guys welcome to level design that the junkers
have cobbled together a convenient route between the market
and battleship all right here we go what here we go let's
see loot yay
we can head inside let me in hey let me in okay he didn't
stop me okay i was gonna say let me in right now and he's
like okay it was never locked dokey it was never locked you
go right in
oh so this is the battleship's interior oh okay that's
pretty this is amazing it's so beautiful let me send a tank
in it's so beautiful time to destroy it all with a tank oh
even the music's nice though oh I love the BGM for this
looks like we've hit a dead end oh there has to be a boss
fight in the sand from the main cannon Blow it all away.
Ha ha!
We're going to destroy...
We're going to destroy a world wonder.
Yeah, I'm inside the ship.
Oh.
What's this?
Yes, that's the way.
No, he's too thick!
Guys, close the door.
Guys, I need you guys to close the door.
Bro, I don't know, guys.
I think my allies are a bit stupid.
Okay, what if I do this and I turn around?
And it's magic.
It's a magic trick.
Guys, you guys like my magic trick?
The door is stuck.
Literally all they had to do was just close the door.
That's all they...
Wait, can I...
Oh, they have invisible walls for a reason.
reason.
They doki-proofed it.
Where did the guys with the jump bot go again?
They did not doki-proof it.
You'll most likely be on the upper levels given the ship's
layout.
Up, huh?
Got it!
Alright.
We got more B grade stuff.
I assume like, okay there must be loot around here, right?
Because we have to go to the top.
So there must be, like, hidden loot right here.
We're judging by my gamer skills.
There must...
Okay.
Just not here, apparently.
Here we go.
I guess not here.
Alright.
Yellow!
Thank God for the yellow.
So I make sure.
I mean...
There has to be loot around...
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
What the fuck?
They actually used my...
double jump?
There should be loot right here, right?
Like, extra loot?
Because, like, look, there's this.
Have I jumped on this platform and then here?
What?
What the fuck?
Guys, you just watched me jump like that?
You're not gonna be helped, though?
Surely, right?
Like, huh?
Oh, there's, like, What?
I can't stand on the pipes?
But what?
That's fucked up, yo.
They wouldn't let me stand on the pipes, guys.
No floor.
Okay, this way.
What the heck happened here?
The place is a mess.
I got...
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
anyway can i get it you're my little pog champ come here
thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you whoa whoa i
keep falling that's why i told you to watch your wait
someone's coming what who is it oh there it is there's the
boss fight
all right it's time to grab the tank give me a sec Pause!
Pause, guys!
Pause!
There you go.
Thank you for all grouping up together.
Nice.
Reloading?
Is that it?
Oh, that was easy.
Oh, my god, he said bot.
Sorry, I thought...
I don't think they have access to such advanced technology.
Bro, that sounded like dumb fuck.
I was like...
Oh!
Defender S.
One of the nasty relics of that foolish...
war hey bls be gentler next time so we can use this stuff
later did not sound like that i was like oh my god he is a
demon we gotta go this way all right nice we got a
battleship one obtained oh we got a map of this i thought i
already have the map of it i guess we have a map of it here
See?
Semi-A- Good.
The door won't open.
I'm gonna beat you up.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna beat you up with my fist.
Oh, I've doubled up!
Let's find another room.
Alright.
Performing leg sweep.
Allows you to evade mid-jump.
Focuses your energy releasing.
We'll let you...
Okay, I think I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do an air cock.
let's see the rare moments i get to fight i feel like uh
we'll do air combo i feel air combo will be better all right
and then let's see what is the poison gas item picker
destroy nearby rocks and collect all available the enemy is
gifted a bomb okay you're gonna start collecting stuff
that's good that's actually more helpful than whatever the
fuck the sheriff is doing
Where are...
Hey guys, I have a feeling one of them is more helpful than
the other.
Wow, I knew the interior was so huge.
I'm straining my neck just looking at the ceiling.
Okay, case in point.
We can't reach the upper levels.
We can jump.
Let's try approaching from below then.
items here all right whoop we got one of the steers but um
oh my god there were stairs this whole time oh sorry that
was a close call oh hey there's a dead guy red dude who the
fuck is a red dude is it the the the Oh, wait, what the
fuck?
It's the Royal Army?
Guys, the girl doesn't need upgrades.
She's already perfect.
She's just there to upgrade my tank.
It's mine.
Doki, he's old.
Give him some slack.
Tank time.
Boom.
Boom!
Guys, is this overkill?
No.
That thing is ever...
What was this gonna do?
Explode?
Oh, shit!
Guys.
I think it exploded, guys.
Oh, wait.
There's stuff here.
Guys, you want to see a magic trick?
Watch this.
Abercadabra.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Watch this.
Averkidap.
Pretty sure I could get over that with a hijack.
Sorry, there was a delay.
Guys, sorry.
My magic trick was lagging, guys.
Guys, it's understandable, okay?
My magic trick was lagging, okay?
There's like...
I'm on a...
I'm on an East Coast server at the moment, so it lagged a
little.
Is this open open sesame.
Oh, I definitely need to take locked inside They're not
locked in here.
I'm not locked in here with them I'm locked.
They're locked in here with me Say less Oh, hey, they can
jump too.
What the fuck am I not special?
The door is unlocked yeah
Which way this way Get locked inside again.
Stay alert.
Yay.
Where'd I go?
Yeah, what's this?
That switch probably controls this elevator.
Where?
Try turning it on.
Wait, where?
Oh, here.
Can I turn it on in my tank?
No, I have to get off the tank.
Oh my god, I thought I was going to get off the railing.
What?
No?
Where's the switch?
Oh my god.
What?
Bro, get up there.
Excuse me?
Goodbye.
Hello?
Excuse me?
It's up here.
Is this...
Okay Guys the elevator was the floor all along guys Guys the
elevator was the floor How the fuck was I supposed to know
There was a switch next to the elevator
Alright here we go Alright here we go Oh wrong way one.
There you go.
Is there another fight here?
No.
I just have to go forward.
I like how the... Oh!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, there you go.
We're fine.
This is not overkill.
So you reload this real fast, too.
A crane for lifting containers.
You think if we shoot the arm, we might be able to use the
container as a platform where's the arm oh this is the arm
boom all right we gotta get off here all right up we go here
we go here we go and up here up here yeah wait there's a
yellow guys there's a yellow door and we know what that
means thank god for all the yellow
Yellow door.
There's a secret here.
There's a secret.
Have I been here?
Oh my god, there's a secret.
Look at all the yellow doors!
Not a good place to call it.
Okay, don't worry.
Ooh.
Look at all these yellow doors!
Whoops, wrong one.
Sorry.
Don't worry, I got you.
Okay, and then reload.
Oh, I'm not you!
Oh, God.
How did I miss?
There you go.
Oh, my God.
Look at all these yellow doors for me.
I'm so far away from the objective.
Wait, the yellow stopped.
Is the yellow here?
Oh, there's the yellow light.
There's the yellow light.
Where's the blue light?
Where is it?
Oh, no!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Don't worry.
My ship is okay.
There you go.
Okay, we gotta grab the mats, though.
Mats time.
Assumulate.
Alright.
Where are...
Don't worry.
My tank is okay.
Guys.
My tank will be okay.
Where the fuck is the loot?
What did I get?
You have acquired an option module that have various
effects.
Use them to gain advantage in battles.
Their special parts cannot be crafted or upgraded on their
own.
Their own effects grow together with the vehicle's level.
Activate using L, B, and RT.
After using an active effect, you must wait for the
cooldown.
Oh!
Prince, I can't lend you a hand.
Wait, I had to activate my...
Oh, my God.
I thought he was trying...
He was already doing that for me.
Alright, guys.
Is there any doors back here?
Just in case?
Alright, no doors.
Alright.
So I can customize my...
Where is it?
Is it this?
Automatic fires.
Ooh, automatic fires.
Okay, guys.
Guys.
Guys, I'm sorry.
Is it this?
Oh!
That's so cool.
Activated it.
Alright, we gotta go back.
Okay, I think I gotta heal my tank a little bit.
Just a...
Just a maybe.
Just...
Um...
Just a maybe.
How do I...
Okay, restore...
There we go.
We did it.
There came a point where, like, I was like, ooh, there was
maybe a little bit too much.
A little bit too much glowy.
Wait, have I been through there?
Wait, there's another yellow door.
Is this where I came from?
Oh, this is where I came from.
Wait, there's a level 16?
Guys, I think I could take him.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I think I can take him.
Watch this.
Guys, watch this.
You know why?
No.
Because he can't come in through here.
Guys, watch this.
There's no way.
Watch, guys.
I can take him.
Guys, what is he gonna do?
Go through that door?
That's fucking right.
What are you going to do about it?
That's right.
Oh, he went through the door.
Guys, guys, he went through the door.
He was not too thick.
I thought he'd be too thick, guys.
Guys, he was not thick.
He was appropriately sized.
it that's okay that's okay he's so far from me it's okay the
ricochet from this he's too far he's too far we did it i
knew we could do it guys look at that i get seven xp for
that That's a bullshit.
Oh my god.
That's actually bullshit.
I can't believe I only get like 7 XP.
I can't believe it.
That was a bounty, right?
That had to be a bounty.
But the loot token.
But how am I going to level up?
It's all about the levels.
think chat think that was not worth it whoa i thought i died
from that did i get there okay this way this way and now
walk over from here and then yay oh here we go okay now yay
hey we're through the door Okay, this is like...
Wait, can I...
No, help me!
Help me loot!
There's so much loot here.
Wait, where am I?
There has to be... There's a level 5 thug here!
Let's beat him up.
That's fucking right, give me your lunch money.
Wait, am I supposed... Oh wait, nice.
Great little chip.
Yeah!
All right, we go here.
Okay, guys, guys, guys, guys, pause, pause, pause, pause,
guys.
Guys, pause, pause, guys, pause.
Thank you for waiting.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god, holy shit, that actually hurt.
At least they waited, though.
And we go this way.
Loot Yeah Is there loot here?
Loot, loot, loot, loot No!
Guys, close the door!
Don't you hate it when the homies don't close the door?
Abra Kadabra Ooh, magic.
Wait, what?
Oh, there it is.
I was like, I swore I saw, like, glowing stuff.
Yay!
Heavy Galen gun.
What's that?
A trap.
There's no traps here.
Get over here.
Fight me at my level.
There you go.
Yeah!
That's the worst trap ever.
Tango!
And Super Wifu!
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, we go up.
Let's see.
Okay, that is where...
The actual thing is there's no loot here, so we'll go this
way.
Alright, hello guys.
Hello.
That's fucking right, get down.
Fight me at my level.
Ooh, that's a big boy.
Yellow!
Loot, loot, loot, loot, loot.
Loot, loot, loot.
There's loot here.
Where's the yellow?
You can't just bait me with the yellow and then disappear
like that.
Here we go.
There it is.
Luke.
He's just a little guy.
Yeah, he is.
Okay, parkour.
There's more over there.
Nice.
And that's how you parkour.
I'm a gamer.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
I think that was everything.
yet to do the walk of shame.
Not me.
Thank God for the yellow lights.
I'm so glad they thought of everything.
Can I just run past it?
Oh, no, I can't.
It's okay.
I've killed your dad.
You're nothing.
Oh my god, he did so much damage.
Okay, maybe he is something.
There you go.
Guys, there is a possibility that he is something.
Oh, this looks like a boss room.
100%.
Eh, I guess not.
Not really.
Actually.
It's just two guys.
What are two guys gonna do?
Boop.
Wait, I missed?
There you go.
At least, that was sort of fun.
Yay!
I have so much mats right now.
I have not used a single...
I just noticed I have so much mats, but I'm not actually
used anything.
Oh, I...
Oh, loot.
Okay.
I haven't upgraded anything on my tank.
I wasn't allowed to!
There was nothing to upgrade.
I swear!
at all if there was i would have upgraded like years ago all
right grab this
there you go oh wait i missed no he just moved there you go
yay heavily i can't fucking oh blast those boxes open this
place is practically falling apart
going steady oh wait that's an abyss let's proceed with care
we gonna keep running loot loot where where is it where is
it they can't bait me like this
okay I need to be a loot goblin okay we got nope uh guys I
think my tank will be okay and then here is that all of them
that should be all of them I see it I see the glowing box
guys oh here we go I have to get it I see something shiny
and I must have Have it.
Bro, I'm afraid of you.
Yeah, chase me down first if you want to do anything.
Here we go.
Boop.
Oh.
Whoa!
Ow!
Don't make me mad.
Don't make me angry.
I'm coming over here.
That's fucking right.
I'll spare you.
Tell your friends.
Wait.
Guys, pause.
I need to upgrade my stuff.
Uh, wait.
The damage sucks.
What the fuck?
It's not even bigger damage.
Oh, wait.
No, that's not even bigger damage.
The damage is terrible.
I lied to.
Okay.
This way.
More ammo.
I don't need ammo.
I'm all in on the damage.
Zero defense, full damage.
If I kill them first, then like, I won't get hurt.
I won't get hit.
All right, this way.
Whoa.
Whoa, we went 2D here.
What?
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Wait, but how do I...
I didn't expect it.
At least that was sort of fun.
I did not expect the 2D part.
We went 2D, 3D.
Now it's a real platformer.
Yeah.
I know there was loot back here.
Huh.
Yeah.
Nothing gonna do.
Nothing.
It's just gonna explode anyway.
Yay!
crash bandy good time yeah i was like what the fuck it just
came out of nowhere yeah tank time go tank go
nice goodbye goodbye i need a platform for my tank yay no
one expects the two the Inquisition.
What's that?
It's a jumper.
Is that the jumper?
That's not just anybody.
It's a jump bot.
Oh my god.
Is that mine?
He looks so cool.
I'm done playing with you now.
He's cooler because there's more color on it.
It looks so too.
I love the texture on that model chat i feel like the
texture on this 3d model looks like it looks it looks 2d
that's actually insane i can't pretend i didn't just hear
that pipsqueak
hmm didn't your daddy teach you it's wrong to take things
that don't belong to you your budget right now for the scene
whatever i want for myself
more than one hour of video games though apparently look
they ran out of money they had him make do with the long
chair we're here on a job to deal with that jump bot from a
junkers market resident can't we just work out a peaceful
solution no peaceful does he look like peaceful
What?
You not used to seeing girls either?
Nah, what I'm interested in is your necklace.
Necklace?
Bet I could get a damn good price for it.
I'll take that as payment.
No way.
I'll never give this up, no matter what.
Yeah, no.
Too bad.
I ain't in the habit of letting it go
Well What the fuck where did he what he's so fast?
Oh wait, it's a different person I was like whoa Give it
back that necklace means everything to me stand back and
it's my turn to repay you For what yeah for what you'd say?
even you're no match for my jump bot demon boy holy shit
there's missiles on that jump bot oh god guys guys remember
i said i don't need heals okay i'm gonna repair my i
realized that i might need a re wait wait wait interception
do your thing intercept oh no i could reload i didn't go
into the fight i didn't reload while guys guys i made the
most fatal mistake i didn't reload
what oh the would not reloading before the fight guys i i
made i made the most common mistake oh no he's gonna get
crazy guys he's gonna jump Fucking crazy Where am I looking
at?
What is that?
Oh, I have to play my ace in the hole.
What this?
Don't you prince get ready to dodge Guys, I did it Okay, I'm
fucking putting on our autopilot Shit, no, the autopilot was
a mistake guys Oh
Oh my god, controller aiming.
Nitro!
Okay.
Nice for five.
We're halfway through.
Come on!
Critical!
Alright, here you go.
Oh, I can shoot him while he's just standing there.
Oh my god, thank god.
Thank god I could just, like, you know, shoot him out of the
air thank god he just stands there menacingly oh come on
just stay stay stay he's gonna blow up oh no i didn't miss
guys that was a hit and then oh my god he's only he's one hp
he's one hp goodbye yes
here thank you bls What happened to the other person?
Yeah, what did I what did what did she do?
Oh the bullet you took a bullet for him.
I remember It's the bullet you know BL you're a pretty
stand-up guy
Not to bring down the mood but you did a real number on the
bot BLs No My new toy!
Nah, I think we can work with this.
Oh, thank God.
All those items I hoarded finally.
It's gonna be used for something.
Warframe is still intact.
I can figure out the rest somehow or other.
Let's get back to Spino and rebuild this thing then.
Let this be a lesson to you to change your way.
Yeah.
Evil doesn't pay.
There can only be one evil person in the world.
Don't encroach in my territory.
Level up!
Yay!
Okay, what can I get?
Raise his power and perform a leg sweep.
A leg sweep.
Boost power of B attacks.
Oh, okay, wait.
I want to boost power of X attacks.
Uh, you know what?
want to boost power of x attacks later i feel like that's
the best one for upgrades um i feel like am i gonna get more
allies because there's three there's three like silhouettes
at the top so does that mean i'm gonna have more allies
later let's get this a boot okay do i care duration of
increases duration of vehicle warfare when he draws hostile
vehicles towards his tank temporary increase towards oh what
what You have your own tank?
Okay.
Help.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
I didn't realize he has his own tank.
I was afraid I'd blown my chance at writing a jump bot for a
second.
Prince, you need to learn to control yourself.
Try and thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, super sticker.
We got what we came for, right?
Oh, wait, there's items here.
Nice.
But I was hoping we'd have more time to hunt for parts The
wannabe junkers may be gone But the defenders are still
around So don't even think about coming in here alone I know
I know I'd never be that reckless Probably Alright time to
leave Time to go back to back home Move
Alright time to leave yay wait am i oh i've been here before
okay i'll have to do is just drop down yay and then it
should be here right can i just fast travel what's this yeah
oh my god just fast travel thank god i'm like i am not
walking back there what's wrong aren't you going in yeah
what's going on i am It's just there's an urgent news
bulletin on the radio now.
Of course, there's no fall damage.
I'm a demon.
Okay.
Yesterday, a Royal Army tank was hijacked from that base by
unknown saboteurs.
Hmm.
The perpetrators have gone on a rampage with their stolen
tank, looting vital water supplies and destroying several
towns.
what the anyone who has recently cited a suspicious tank
should contact a royal army immediately this is not
suspicious guys I know they're asking for like our tank is
number tank 42 30 million bro I'm just gonna turn myself in
guys why don't we just cross out the four and break 105
we didn't do of that of course i mean mayor tore trusts you
guys so
damn it how could the royal army sink so low bro just
rewrite just get fucking paint and rewrite the name to spend
the rest of our lives on the run oh my god guys we can like
get paint
30 million is 30 true like i said i turned myself in oh i
went the wrong way i thought i was like wait a minute why am
i leaving
30 million is 30 million guys come on i you turned me in if
it was 30 million all right what the fuck string serum wait
where's my home There's like ceiling lights army based.
What will I do with 50 chairs?
Wait, did I rob the base like here?
Thank you for the gifted chips.
Thank you.
Thank you, bro, I get 50 windows 50 consoles.
Oh my god Bro, what the fuck am I gonna do with all these
items?
let's see apparently i robbed something all right parts
upgrade part i can upgrade yay which one's the one that i
equipped though is it the green can't tell
customized vehicle uh oh wait it is okay it's the green okay
that has 97 damage 24 wait what's this what's the oh attack
interval um well it's uncommon so it should be better right
let's see uh upgrade oh this is the one i equipped okay i'm
gonna upgrade this might as well yay i may have so much
money i might as well you know
upgrade nice uh
sanita thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i
can't afford 30 minutes but here's my part to turn yourself
in thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh i can
upgrade my vehicle oh wait might as well you know
oh okay we gotta get chip slot guys okay and then get that
level two and get that level three and i might as well get
that level four wait how much can i do oh okay level five
just fall in god my tank is so tanky now okay i only have
one dragon thank you the super chat thank you what do you
call an old snowman a glass of water thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you all right let's see i can finally
add a chip Chip quick reload power plus chip.
Okay, we gotta get the cannon the cannon has been like the
lifesaver All right, nice.
How do I decorate my village?
Our only hope is to find that spring as soon as we can Let's
abandon the tank and forget all about this we got lucky they
still don't know who we really are Some demon you are thief
don't be such a coward But brains I'll keep looking for the
spring all on my own if I have to look you chose this guy to
join us We could have got the cool centaur I wanted a
centaur Let me be clear.
I'm not turning back until I've seen that spring with my own
eyes If you can't handle that then go home already But what
will everyone say if they see me return without you?
Yeah, um, well, then you're just a bad guardian.
I'm sure things will work out.
Once the jump bot's ready, I just know we'll find the
spring.
How can you be so sure?
You're a gutsy one, aren't you?
Oh, what?
We're out of town now?
Where's our, where's the woman?
Anne's fine working on that jump bot all on her own.
Wait, exactly!
I spent all my money upgrading the tank, and now they want a
bad...
what the fuck we're better off getting some rest for the
journey ahead we're going to be aimlessly wandering through
the southern desert with an entire army on our tail don't
worry I live in the south 30 years ago so I at least know
the general lay of the land there ah 30 years ago you mean
back when the peachy still inhabited the area oh by when the
aliens the royal army wiped them all out he was part of the
massacre he's a bad old person we need to push him such a
tragedy that made my list of the top 10 most foolish things
wait what's number one humanity has ever done foolish but it
prevented the peachy from destroying all of Sandland with
their doomsday weapon.
Is that a doomsday weapon?
Really?
You actually believe that?
Astor, thank you for the magenta.
Super.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
I've been loving the streams I've been able to catch.
Also super excited for the Rob the Bank merch to ship.
Thank you.
We might be able to ship it beginning of the next month.
So I'm super excited.
The machine we really do.
Oh my God.
He got influenced by propaganda.
He got propagandas.
what water no that can't be oh my god are peaches like the
piccolo's in this universe it's true all right the brilliant
i forgot the name of their species the something it starts
with an n right not just for themselves but to share with
everyone that's a dead boy thank you for the I'll get the
chips, they can thank you.
Yeah, the Namikin.
Namik, Namik, not something.
Namikikin.
Because the Royal Army's prophets would go up in smoke if
that happened.
They got rid of the peachy first.
The massive explosion that happened when they were attacked
was caused by the aquarium they needed to make their machine
work.
Which the Royal Army gave them knowing what would have.
happen and the Royal Army used a massive Aquanium bomb to
wipe out every last one of them no but this is when he
realized how badly he fucked up before then he was like okay
I was just doing my orders and it can't be that bad now he
realized everything he doomed humanity the commander of them
who ordered the shots that set off the Aquanium.
Was it you, Sheriff?
It was you, wasn't it?
I do it!
Okay, we like sort of called this in like...
We literally...
We're like, bro, he obviously used to be from the army.
Resulting explosion destroyed almost my entire village.
And everyone in my whole brigade apart from me was killed.
in an instant guys i wrote this game i ghost wrote this game
guys
they they made us attack now he has more trauma that
explosion wait if they knew why would they make your tanks
attack inside the blast radius bro stop spoiling the game
dokey our brigade never much like supreme commanders they
use methods we spoke our minds too much
oh well not your fault huh you had no idea he still killed
people he's still bro he literally wiped out an entire race
you can't just be like he was just following orders he knew
what he still The context of wiping the entire race just
changed He still did it
Like he's still Like it just changed the context of him Wipe
the reasoning why he wiped the entire race
But then The peachy were really developing a machine machine
that made water the real faint here it's you wait he murders
a massive equine he actually murders bro the demons can't
even kill but he can is actually me what
the fuck is he doing give me a sec I'm gonna turn into a
giant monkey right now.
Sorry, wrong manga.
What in the world?
The Toriyama cinematic universe.
Because it looks like we're in for a fight.
Guys, my game crashed.
Okay, I think that's a good time to call it.
Okay, I'm gonna call it here.
I mean, we had a lot.
We played for...
We played for four hours.
Did it save?
Well, it has auto-saves, so I think we'll be fine.
Honestly, I've been enjoying it so far.
I don't know.
Let's see how long this game is.
Let me see.
Sandland.
How long is the game?
Let me look it up.
How long is Sandland?
It took me 32 hours to finish Sandland.
Oh my god, okay, um, I'll think about it.
25, okay, okay, I'm gonna think about it, guys.
I'm not gonna give you guys any promises.
If there's a cut to, if there's a part two, there's a part
two.
If you never see a part two again, you know why.
Okay, I'll think about it, guys.
I'm gonna think about it chat We'll We'll have that fun
though I had a lot of fun though chat This has been like
pretty enjoyable Like the action RPG part Um But I'll
definitely think about it guys If we'll do a part two Uh but
I definitely enjoy it a lot so far Um was a spot No no it
wasn't sponsored I just really want to check it out on
launch After like Uh it was like post i can't i don't want
to post he posthumously released after you know after
toriama what happened toriama and i really want to check it
out because i talked about this before but i grew up my my
uncle was a huge toriama fan and like he owned like a lot
like everything he owned like all his manga like all the
manga that he ever wrote and like uh i think like one of my
i remember i remember one of my favorite one shots that he
did was uh i think it's called kajika and like he owned
everything and then like it wasn't just like dragon ball z
or dragon ball or like dr sub every single one shot that was
published um my uncle owned owned all of them um and i would
like hang out in his room reading all the monk like all of
his manga and stuff and i thought like Oh, I really wanted
to, you know, I, uh, really wanted to, um, check out this
game as, like, uh, you know, like, uh, because I've never
really played, uh, uh, I guess, like, a Toriyama game on PC
before.
Um, the last time I played a game based off of any of
Toriyama's works was, um, the Dragon Ball Z game on the Game
Boy Advance.
And that was, like, the only time I've ever uh one of his uh
one of his like works being adapted to a video game i never
even like played any of like the you know like the dragon
monster like fighter games i never played any of those on pc
so i figured like oh you know it's a good time to check it
out uh and i it was pretty enjoyable so far i've had a great
time checking out uh checking out sandland it was really
cool that bandai dropped by i i was like oh my god they
noticed me guys bandai noticed me dragon quest guys of
course i haven't played dragon quest i told you about me and
jrpgs guys i i am i usually i am not like like jrpgs are not
my preference that's why when i saw action jrpg i was like
oh my god
I like action So I was like That's for me So that's why I
was like Okay I'll check it out Just because it's action
Anyway guys I'm gonna call it here Tomorrow's a rest day And
then Saturday's sort of like a rest day Because there's only
like It's like Good Night Dragoons on Saturday But I hope
you guys Enjoyed today's stream Everybody I always have
great time streaming for you guys As always everyone around
to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh my God, secret ending!
I just got an email from one of the represent bandad.
They want to send me a collector's edition of Sandland.
Guys, I'm getting free shit!
Okay, we're going to do a part two of Sandland.
They're like, thank you for streaming Satellite.
We want to send you a collector.
Okay, we're good.
I guess I have to do a part two now.
Anyway, guys, bye for real.
Sorry, wrong screen.
I got so excited.